Ich weiß, heute ist relativ früh, aber nach mir, wenn ich schon wach bin, warum soll ich
da jetzt irgendwie erst eine halbe Stunde später anfallen?
Ah ja, und wie ist euer Wachheitsgrad, falls es so ein Wort gibt?
Also meine ist so 50% würde ich sagen. Ich bin aufgestanden vor ungefähr 40 Minuten.
Also ich bin früher auch immer 6 Uhr bzw. 5 vor 45 aufgestanden, also unter der Woche.
Dementsprechend war ich dann auch Wochenende schon saumäßig früh wach.
Aber seit die ganze Homeoffice-Geschichte ist, schlafe ich länger, dementsprechend bin
ich auch immer eine Stunde später wach und ich gehe auch wenn ich dann auf die Arbeit
gehe später auf die Arbeit und ich muss sagen, das war mir zu der Zeit gar nicht so klar,
wo ich immer um 5 vor 45 aufgestanden bin, aber 5 vor 45 ist ganz schön früh und dementsprechend
bist du eigentlich den ganzen Tag irgendwie im Arsch und weißt nicht genau warum, also
zumindest war das bei mir so, das muss bei dir nicht so sein, und du weißt gar nicht
so genau warum. Erst nachdem ich jetzt einfach mal ein bisschen
später und insgesamt ein bisschen länger gepennt habe, merke ich erst den Unterschied,
das ist der Unterschied zu wie Tag und Nacht. Also wenn man wach ist oder mehr oder weniger
den ganzen Tag so im Halbschlaf, dann ist wach deutlich besser und ich war früher einfach
nicht wach, als ich 5 vor 45 aufstehen musste. Naja ich bin früher auch, deswegen gehe ich
doch immer um 22 Uhr ins Bett, aber ich konnte früher noch nicht um 22 Uhr pennen und kann
jetzt auch noch nicht um 22 Uhr pennen. Also wenn ich um 22 Uhr hier oft gehe, heißt
ja nicht, dass ich instant ins Bett gehe. Also wenn ich 22 Uhr den Stream ausmache, dann
logge ich erst noch mal kurz um auf meinen anderen Account, mache noch ein paar YouTube
Videos an, irgendwann ziehe ich mich um, gehe Zähne putzen, dann lege ich mich rüber, gucke
noch kurz auf mein Smartphone, irgendwas, weil sonst kann ich gar nicht pennen. Also
ich kann nicht instant vom Rechner ins Bett und dann einschlafen, das funktioniert nicht.
Vielleicht hatte das ja auch der ein oder andere früher, also ich habe das früher öfters
gemacht, ich habe keine Ahnung, 14 Stunden am Stück am Rechner irgendwelche MMOs gespielt
oder irgendwas, aber irgendwas gespielt, sei es auch Multiplayer, vollkommen egal. Ich
habe quasi 14 Stunden am Stück Kreiselgrind gemacht und bin dann nachts ins Bett und ich
habe mich quasi direkt vom Gaming am Rechner ins Bett gelegt. Ich bin dazu auch eingepennt,
aber ich habe dann quasi weiter geträumt, als würde ich vorm Rechner sitzen. Das ist
ganz merkwürdig, du sitzt dann auf einmal vorm Rechner, gehst ins Bett und dann träumst
und sitzt vorm Rechner. Du träumst im Prinzip, oder was heißt nicht vorm Rechner, du träumst
von, dass du das spielst, was du gespielt hast am Rechner und das irgendwie sich komisch
verhält und so. Aber gut, ich meine, wenn man 14 Stunden Kreiselgrind gemacht hat, von
was soll man dann auch sonst träumen, außer von Kreiselgrind? Ja, wie gesagt, ich bin
dann wahrscheinlich normalerweise auch nicht vor 23.30 Uhr oder so eingeschlafen und dann
um 5.45 Uhr aufstehen, ich war so im Arsch und ich habe es gar nicht realisiert, dass
ich im Arsch war, wie gesagt, als ich noch um 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden bin. Und warum bin
ich um 5.45 Uhr aufgestanden? Ganz klar, weil ich mit der Bahn fahren musste beziehungsweise
weil es halt ein Stück dauert nach Frankfurt und zurück. Ich habe ja noch versucht morgens
und mittags wenigstens damals schon, also zumindest dann die letzten paar Jahre so halbe
Stunde morgens Bewegung, halbe Stunde abends Bewegung, sonst Bahnhof hin und zurück einzubauen
und dementsprechend habe ich halt einfach mal eine Stunde hingebraucht oder ein bisschen
länger, Stunde 15 hin, Stunde 15 zurück, weil halt hin und zurück laufen. So, und
diese zweieinhalb bis drei Stunden, je nachdem, wenn die Bahn mitmacht, die man sich halt
am Tag spart, die kannst du einfach pennen, du hast dadurch keine Einbußen, außer, dass
du alles das, was du dann machst, besser machen kannst, weil du wach bist. Also, ins Büro
fahren ist gerade für so Bürojobs, wie ich habe, wie ich das habe oder gerade Leute,
die in der IT arbeiten, wo es absolut keinen Sinn macht vor Ort zu sein, das Beste, was
es gibt. Du kannst pennen in der Zeit, wo du sonst Zug gefahren wärst und machst
die Sachen, die du machst, besser. Also es ist eigentlich vorbei. Ich hatte am Freitag
jährliche Rücksprache mit meinem Chef, also so ganz offizielle Rücksprache, so mit Protokoll
und Personalakte und geht uns dieses einmal bei uns im Jahr. Ja, und da habe ich auch
gesagt, Homeoffice ist das Beste, was es gibt. Das hat nur Vorteile für alle. Ja, ich schaffe
unterm Strich mehr und mir geht es besser bei. Also die Firma hat was davon und ich
habe was davon. Also das ist eigentlich die optimale Kombination. Besser geht es gar nicht.
Deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum sich gerade so viele übrigen Managementleute und nicht
nur bei uns so schwer tun mit dieser ganzen Thematik. Ich kann es einfach nicht nachvollziehen.
Ich meine, ich verstehe natürlich, dass es genug Berufe gibt, wo es nicht geht und dass
es bei uns vielleicht auch Bereiche gibt, wo das nicht geht und ich kann mir auch durchaus
vorstellen, dass es Leute gibt, wo das nicht gescheit funktioniert und so. Das ist alles
keine Frage. Aber es gibt auch genug, wo das funktioniert und ich verstehe nicht, warum
da sich so schwer getan wird an vielen Stellen. Und wie gesagt, das ist bei uns nicht der
einzige Laden. Ich kenne es von euch. Ich weiß, also hier vom, ja, also hier, ihr hier,
oder nicht, also noch mehr normalerweise. Nur nicht so viele da. Also ich kenne es hier
aus dem Chat, auch von Twitch. Ich kenne es von den YouTube-Comments. Es gibt überall
Probleme. Das ist tatsächlich so, ja. Man sieht, wo man halt was wirklich Sinnvolles
macht, anstatt einfach nur anwesend zu sein. Das ist wohl, das ist wohl wahr, ja. Wisst
ihr, eine Sache, die ich, muss ich jetzt, muss ich an der Stelle auch mal sagen, eine Sache,
die ich bei mir auf der Arbeit irgendwie vermisse, was Management angeht. Und das ist hauptsächlich
mittleres bis bis oberes Management, also da, wo die Entscheidungen getroffen werden.
Was ich da vermisse, ist, es wird an allen Stellen erzählt so nach dem Motto, ja, man
soll seine Arbeit hinterfragen, ob das überhaupt noch passt zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt. Alles
schön und gut. Aber was ich noch nie, seit ich da bin, und ich bin jetzt ja schon ein
paar Jahre bei der Bank in Frankfurt, wo ich jetzt auch arbeite, was ich noch nie erlebt
habe, ist, dass ab einer gewissen Management-Ebene das mal hinterfragt wurde, was man gemacht
hat. Das mag zwar sein, dass das so persönlich oder bei den Leuten im Kopf passiert, aber
ich habe noch nie mitbekommen, dass irgendjemand gesagt hat, okay, das ist jetzt in die Hose
gegangen, aber mit, weil wir es so entschieden haben. Das habe ich noch nie gehört. Dabei
ist das, liegt das auf der Hand. Die Leute denken sich ja nicht random irgendwas aus,
was sie machen, sondern die Richtung werden ja ab gewissen Management-Ebenen, also die
Weichen werden ja gestellt. Wenn man die falsch stellt, dann muss man zumindest auch mal ein
bisschen die Hintergründe bei sich suchen, warum hat man das denn so entschieden. Vielleicht
war das nicht die beste Idee, das so zu entscheiden, wie man das entschieden hat. Das ist ja nicht
schlimm. Man kann was verkehrt entscheiden, aber man sollte zumindest nicht immer so tun,
als wäre das alles immer perfekt und unfehlbar, weil man sieht, dass das nicht ist und deutlich
glaubhafter wäre, weil man ab und zu mal auch von oberen Management-Ebenen hört, okay,
die Entscheidung war getroffen auf der Basis von Informationen, die uns damals vorlagen,
aber wir haben jetzt gesehen, das kann man besser machen. Das reicht ja schon als Umschreibung
zu wir haben es ein bisschen verkackt. Das wäre ja schon okay, aber das gibt es bei uns
einfach nicht und ich glaube, das gibt es bei ganz wenigen, dass man dort auch mal sagt,
okay, es ist nicht nur verkackt worden, sondern es ist mit verkackt worden, weil wir es so
entschieden haben. Ich finde, das gehört eigentlich mit dazu, wenn man in so einer Entscheidungsposition
ist, aber das sieht man selten. Deswegen nehme ich viele Sachen auch gar nicht mehr ernst.
Es gibt so viele Dinge, die werden bei uns als super krass wichtig neu angekündigt und
dann hörst du nix mehr von. Beispielsweise letztes Jahr, das ist auch so eine geile Story,
letztes Jahr hatten sie oder ich habe es von denen mitbekommen letztes Jahr, also wir hatten
bei uns einen, den haben sie eingestellt dafür, dass der quasi zu jedem Team hingeht oder
im Prinzip letztendlich sogar zu jedem einzelnen, was natürlich als Teamleiter oder so hingeht
und mit dem ihre aktuellen Abläufe bespricht. Und die haben den eingestellt und haben ihm
gesagt, aber hartnäckig sein, dass das auch ordentlich verfolgt wird alles. So und das
geile ist, der Kerl ist jetzt nicht mehr da und wisst ihr warum? Weil er zu hartnäckig
war. Also sprich, der Typ, der ihn eingestellt hat und hat zu ihm gesagt, aber sei hartnäckig,
der war halt auch bei ihm und bei anderen auf dieser Ebene hartnäckig und dann haben
sie gesagt, Moment, Moment, du sollst nicht bei uns hartnäckig sein, du sollst so, das
gefällt uns jetzt auch nicht. Okay, dann haben sie ihn gekickt und haben sie ihn wieder rausgeschmissen.
Das ist so komisch, das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, man möchte
nicht gern mit den eigenen Sachen konfrontiert werden, die man da entschieden hat. 400 Kilometer
Anreiseweg natürlich krass, von wo nach wo ungefähr ist das denn? Das ist ja 400 Kilometer,
kann ja durchaus anderes Land sein fast schon. Der wurde im Prinzip gefeuert, weil er das,
was er machen sollte, auch gemacht hat. Das muss man sich mal überlegen, ja? Also nee,
nee, nee, Moment, Moment. Er wurde gefeuert, weil er das gemacht hat, was ihm gesagt wurde,
dass er machen soll. Aber gemeint hat es wahrscheinlich keiner, aber das konnte der arme Kerl ja nicht
wissen. Ah, das ist schon geil. TS Fuchs, danke für den Sub, hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Huge Subscription. Wie lief es mit dem Sub, oder mit dem Zabbix? Tatsächlich lief das
ganz gut, ja. Ich hab gestern Abend noch ein bisschen weiter gebastelt ohne euch. Ich hab
noch ein Grafana installiert und geguckt, ob man die Crafts embedden kann im Zabbix. Funktioniert
ohne Probleme. Werd ich aber wahrscheinlich nicht benutzen, weil ich komme wahrscheinlich
mit den Standard Zabbix Grafen ganz gut klar. Weil die Grafana-Dinger halt deutlich angenehmer
sind. In Schweden von Tipo nach Malmo. Okay, ich weiß, das hab ich schon gehört, aber
ich hab keine Ahnung, wo das ist. 400km ist heftig. Also 400km hast du wirklich ordentlich
zu tun, wenn ich mir überlege. Das ist fast, das ist ungefähr, wenn ich von hier nach
Dresden fahren würde, das ist schon auch nicht ohne. Weil ich mir gar nicht so sicher bin.
Ich gucke. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie weit das ist. Kommen wir hier, Hanau. Direction from
hier. Kilometer. Kilometer. Ja, sag ich doch, ungefähr. Kommt hin. 54. Halt auch schon.
Zwegau. Ist schon ein Stück, ja. Für schwedische Verhältnisse ist das nicht viel. Okay, also
für weite Verhältnisse ist das viel. Aber Anreiseweg ist schon. 400km ist heftig. Na
ja. Wohnortleak. Oh nein. Das war so secret. Kontinentleak vor allem. Was hab ich denn
hier eigentlich alles noch auf? Das muss ich mal kurz zumachen. Main-Config-Nakios,
das brauchen wir bestimmt nicht. Was zum Teufel ist das? Rest-Posten 70 mal Netgear. Ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen, dass diesen Krempel noch irgendjemand haben will. 350 Dollar Pfund.
Monkeys. But why? Taugen die Dinger überhaupt? Ich weiß ja nicht mal, was ist das. Lass
ich mal kurz gucken. Netgear. Access-Point. Lol. N-A-G-B. Alter, das ist ja uralt. Das
ist ja 2008er Wifi oder so. Warum sollte man da für Geld ausgeben? Vor allem, was will
man denn mit 350 Access-Points oder so? Ja, okay, da biete ich vielleicht drauf. Da biete
ich auch morgen. Okay, da biete ich vielleicht auch drauf. Mal schauen, mal gucken. Ja, machen
wir hier mal zu. Ich muss gerade mal kurz ein bisschen Tabs schließen, Leute. Das machen
wir auch zu. Auch zu, auch zu, auch zu. Auch zu. Was ist das hier? Mein eigenes Video zu.
Zu. Zu, zu, zu, zu. Machen wir alles dicht. Exzellent. Ne. Hab ich ausprobiert, hab ich
wieder uninstalliert. Gibt so ein paar Sachen, da komm ich nicht mit klar und damit bin ich
nicht klargekommen. Moin, Phipps. Du warst doch vorhin auch schon da, oder? Da ist er.
schon er war als erstes da und ist jetzt wieder da ja geht so also ich habe schon ich habe ich
habe selten jetzt dass ich sagen würde richtig richtig gut geschlafen ich habe irgendwie
geschlafen ja aber so richtig gut kann man das nicht nennen was mir wurde gerade im stream
eine werbe banne angezeigt wodurch das seitenverhältnis verschoben wurde und das stream quasi in
den hintergrund ja das kommt vor das habe ich auch schon gesehen das ist dann so dass wenn ich das
wenn ich das das das habe ich auch manchmal wenn man wenn man sich das anguckt dann ist hier die
werbung und hier neben ist dann das video total merkwürdig keine ahnung was ich da twitch
gedacht hat heißt das wirklich null ea wie alt bist du 37 ich werde bald 38 monka es
ja ja ihr müsst euch vorstellen hier sitzt ein fast 38 jähriger sonntags morgens vorm pc und
sagt monka es oder lull hd 4k und spiel gachi roll emotes ab das ende ist nah das denkt man ja
schon lange aber bis jetzt ist das ende noch nicht im sicht ja nee ich sage kein wann ich
geburtstag habe und ich feiere auch keine geburtstagsfeier das einzige was ich mache
ich gehe vielleicht massive pippo fett futtern aber wobei es ist diesen sommer tatsächlich für
meine verhältnisse volles real life programm angesagt also für meine verhältnisse ja volles
real life programm angesagt ich mein bald ist iron maiden in frankfurt dann ist power wolf
frankfurt und dann ist noch plain guardian frankfurt massive gar nicht mehr so lange hin
das reicht mir an an real life kram für dieses jahr ist genug massive metal ja
ich weiß nicht ob power wolf schon als gottesdienst durchgeht
ok nice also was gibt es denn sonst interessantes heute auf youtube ich habe mal hier ein bisschen
refreshed und ich habe nicht allzu viel spannendes gefunden paar sachen hatte ich noch auf dem
handy mittlerweile denkt youtube anscheinend dass wir unbedingt die ganze zeit dieses was
verdient eingucken wollen weil wir uns da schon vier fünf videos vor angeschaut haben was auch
immer die meisten finde ich gar nicht sonderlich spannend die diese ganzen shorts geschichten
ja die sind ja eigentlich dafür gedacht dass man die auf dem handy aufmacht und dann irgendwie
drei stunden durchscrollt ich klicke meistens einen short an dann lasse ich den durchlaufen
und denke mir so ja teilweise ganz interessant guck mir den nächsten short an denk mir so
teilweise ganz interessant und ich mir warum guckst du den scheiß eigentlich an und da
mache ich wieder zu weil meistens ist es noch nicht mal interessant meistens ist das so ok
wie kann man das beschreiben was man in shorts meistens sieht shorts ist oftmals nicht wirklich
interessant so dass man sagen könnte auch cool da habe ich was gelernt oder auch cool das ist
interessant zu wissen oder etwas kann ich mal die shorts sind meistens so dinge die in irgendeiner
art und weise irgendwie satisfying anzugucken sind ja sei es dass irgendwelche leute löcher
ins eis schneiden oder dass irgendwas cooles in games passiert haben sie übrigens immer
irgendwelche hotten grills gerne in den vorschau bildern das mit den videos manchmal gar nichts
großartig zu tun hat und letztendlich ist der inhalt von shorts also meistens ziemlich sinnlos
aber trotzdem eine art von content die man permanent angucken kann ich weiß nicht wie
ich das klassifizieren soll also man kann es gucken ohne gelangweilt zu sein aber man hat
absolut gar nichts davon im endeffekt was nicht schlimm ist ich meine das könnte man ja von zu
fast zu fast allem sagen ich meine es gibt genug leute die haben gerade gerade wo ich noch jünger
war die haben zu allem was gaming war und so gesagt das bringt doch nichts ist doch zeitverschwendung
letztendlich wenn es ein unterhältner spaß dran hat da finde ich das nicht irgendwie würde ich
nicht sagen dass das zeitverschwendung ist aber das ist so es aber so shorts ist halt so unterhaltung
zum größten teil ohne irgendwie substanz ja es ist es ist irgendwie auch passend so zu aktuellen
zuschauer vorleben halt auf youtube hat schon seinen grund warum die das eingeführt haben
sie ist worden hat neues battlefield wie die zukunft von battlefield 2042
ja gut das spiel hat eine zukunft weil man kann die zeit nicht aufhalten aber
das spiel hat keine zukunft insofern entfernt von dass es mal irgendwie noch sind nennenswert
spieler bekommen da müssten die schon ganz komische dinge machen die ich mir gerade nicht
ausmalen kann was es sein oh ja das ist was für mich das ist das passende boomer video für
mich heute heute morgen die lab sounds beim was ist das eigentlich für ein messer 5 hat modem
hier das sieht überhaupt nicht aus wie von 1995 1995 von 95 das sieht richtig advanced aus
modem die lab sound ne ne ne ne das ist das ist das nicht das gute hier das hier das hier
ist das gute 6 56 k beste ja genau beste das klingt nur bei amis so das hat bei uns nicht
so geklungen exzellent 1990 da gab es nicht mal htp das ist egal ob es htp gab oder nicht
die lapen konntest du schon ich mein man ist damals hat sich eingewählt mit dem modem auch
also nicht auch nicht unbedingt um das internet zu verwenden ja da gab es leute die haben
irgendwelche mail boxen gehabt dann gab es btx und solche komischen dinger das macht
nichts dass da htp nicht angesagt war ich weiß ich wann wann wurde denn htp erfunden
reveal date kann ich nicht in wendet in wendet hier ok zwischen gut wirklich durchgesetzt
hat sich natürlich erst ein bisschen später also ich kann mich noch daran erinnern wisst
ihr wisst ihr was 1997 oder 1998 rum meine top besuchte kann ich mich heute noch dran
erinnern was ich damals immer als erstes für eine webseite aufgemacht habe das könne
ich was counter strike counter strike de habe ich die weiß keine ob sie seite noch gibt
habe ich da immer aufgemacht weil ich habe immer mit morgens bender comics die seite
damals anders aus das kann nicht sein ich habe mir immer bender comics angeguckt das
war bestimmt nicht 2004 war vielleicht was counter strike de so ohne bindestrich ja
counter strike de war es wahrscheinlich kennt noch jemand die counter strike bender comics
diese dinger das habe ich immer morgens darauf gegeiert ob es neue gab und man muss ja auch
sagen counter strike war 98 wirklich der neueste shit überhaupt das war counter strike war
so ich 052 oder so als half life mod einer hat das ding wirklich competitive gespielt
damals die leute haben mehr oder weniger mehr geiselrettung gespielt als bomben legen und
haben in salt im luftschacht gekämpft oder am eingang oder so das war kannst du mit heute
mit heute cs nicht wirklich vergleichen oh man ja gut also was gucken wir uns dann internet
teile maschinei das kommt man sehen unify protect application nein ganz bestimmt gar
nicht unify habe ich bei mir ausgeschmissen das bleibt doch erst mal raus was 360 320
foff ok 320 foff das ist 320 foff ah ne jetzt kommt foff 320 ist nicht so viel anders aus
aber moment es kommt jetzt noch wir spulen ja gut die call of duty ist damals war nicht
unbedingt drauf ausgelegt so los foff zu haben kennt ihr noch die ganzen sniper clips von
früher wo die leute teilweise so ultra krasses foff hatten wurde schon quasi gesehen hast
dass der arm aus der kamera klitscht bei bewegung mittlerweile haben sie sehr glücklicherweise
besser gemacht müssen sie ja auch ich meine heutzutage sind bildschirme verbreitet die
auflösungen haben von ich weiß es gar nicht was haben diese ganzen ultra weit screen dinger
für eine auflösung da brauchst du schon ein bisschen foff ja quasi so viel wie zwei normale
bildschirme nebeneinander ok was komm wir lassen uns level was ok dieses video wurde
mir gerade vorhin auf der startseite empfohlen das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken weil ich
habe keine ahnung was youtube mir damit sagen möchte aber anscheinend ist das jetzt sehr
angesagt aktuell jet power blower also irgendeiner hat eine turbine oder sowas an den stap keine
ahnung ok also jet power blower kann man die qualität hochstellen ne alter 2019 oder 480
was zum ok ist da unten so ein gewähr gewährt zwei bein treepot oder b pot nicht treepot
warum warum hat er eine turbine um damit wahrscheinlich schnee weg zu pusten oder so oder ne ist das
schnee oder oder split split oder so weg zu pusten es sieht aus wie aus garrys mod da
hast du recht ja es geht es geht los also was richtig geil wenn der typ ist einfach zwei
meter zurück fliegt und man würde erstmal denken das geht doch gar nicht dass er zurück
fliegt aber ich denke mir mal von der das kann durchaus ordentlich schub generieren
das ding ich meine abheben wir damit nicht aber mal gucken man kann es hier gar nicht
aber also dass man da ordentlich rumrutscht mit könnte könnte ich mir schon vorstellen
ok da muss ich schon reinlehnen ok den sinn der konstruktion habe ich immer noch nicht
genau verstanden es ist brutals laut auf jeden fall
was ich der typ jetzt wohl denkt er da grad dran vorbei fährt vor ihr fahrt da vorbei
ja das haut schon ganz schön rein das ding ok äußerst effektiver schnee weg das ist
gar kein schnee das ist wasser das ist ja bescheuert und zu aber es haut ordentlich
rein guck mal da kann kaum stehen bleiben krasser scheiß absolut unsinnig aber krasser
scheiß was schmachs denn alter oh hier ist eine motte moment wo ist sie hin ich hab sie
erwischt aber nicht richtig ich hab sie so weit erwischt dass sie nur noch nur noch
weg weg reisen weg fliegen konnte aber sie ist weggeflogen was schaut ihr wieder an
ja irgendein typ hat sich ein turbine getriebenen gebläse gebaut warum auch immer ich glaube
für laub ist es noch nicht mal wirklich gut weil du pustest das laub dann quasi mehr
oder weniger nicht auf einen haufen sondern quasi random von einer ecke in die andere
vielleicht und nicht dass du es irgendwie auf den haufen gepustet bekommst und auch
nicht so dass du ordentlich zusammen rechnen kannst glaubt es ist ein bisschen zu aufer
im
Hier ist was passiert. Lass mich mal raten. Gar nichts.
Oder vielleicht overflowen irgendwelche
Timer und das Ding kackt ab. Man weiß es nicht.
Alles klar, so.
Wir lassen uns mal eine Runde Chebaden von Level Cap, wenn wir grad dabei sind.
Der Level Cap Chebade.
Das...
Das ist doch nichts neues.
Das wusste man doch, dass mit der Season nur eine Map kommt.
Zumal ich von Anfang an gesagt hab, dass das halt
das Mindeste ist, was sie liefern müssen, dass die das Spiel schon längst aufgegeben haben.
Das ist das Mindeste, was sie liefern müssen, dass sie das Spiel schon längst aufgegeben haben.
längst aufgegeben haben es ist das mindeste was sie liefern müssen dass sie
bei den Amis nicht verklagt werden weil sie es versprochen haben dass es kommt
ansonsten wird das nichts daran ändern ich predikte für das video was der
erzählt das jetzt und am ende und am ende hier im outro sagt er let me know
what you think will one map save battlefield 2042 oder irgendwie sowas
das ist immer das ist der typische level capture bait auf geht's
revealed key changes coming to battlefield 20 changes leute ich krieg
bei diesem schick ich krieg bei allen sachen total ausrasst aber diesem game
das spiel ist über ein halbes jahr draußen und jetzt fällt jetzt überlegen
sie sich gerade was man denn ändern könnte um an diesem spiel noch was es
ist alle das ist so ein kack das ist so verkackt so verkackt man okay weiter
22 modern warfare twos release date was announced halo infinite might be in
trouble in much more on this weekend game okay das ist ein developer update
video this week significant map changes are promised for kaleidoscope in renewal
diesen ja geil maps werden spielbar nach sieben acht monaten mal und im
prinzip wenn man sich anguckt was die da erzählt haben in dem ich habe das
allerletzte developer update nicht gesehen sondern nur das davor
im prinzip gab es ein paar kisten auf kaleidoscope dazu und irgendwie ein paar
zeune oder so also es ist es hielte sich es hielte sich stark in grenzen
involves complete overhauls to their layouts and playable areas
was ist man gespannet new cover and asset wait a minute das hat tatsächlich
gar nicht so steuerensübel aus der layouts and playable areas
die maps sieht jetzt mehr nach einem map aus anstatt einfach drei dinger
hingestellt auf eine ebene das ding okay das ist das das ding sieht aus gerade
mit diesen plöcken das sieht eins zu eins aus als hätte man die letzte base
von dem event peak genommen kennt ihr noch die letzte base von dem event peak
da war das bestand hier hinten war dann das sieht aus als hätte man die base
von dem event peak genommen und er hätte die jetzt quasi rein copy pasted in
kaleidoscope
das ist ziemlich nah dran an der letzten base von dem event peak sogar
du hast hier den einger okay du hast hier neben nicht die straße
wobei du hast hier die straße das ist relativ nah dran aber gut ich meine
diese bases sehen in allen battlefields so aus
new cover das sieht aus wie die letzte base von dem event peak
und assets to make the mass more believable the updated version of
kaleidoscope das problem ist das ist cool ja aber ich meine es ist nicht so dass die
map dadurch jetzt auf einmal spielbar wird ich mein guckt euch mal vorher an
vorher war es halt einfach nur mega beschissen weil du hattest keine deckung
du hattest hier oben diese komischen dinger was auch immer das sein soll
wo sich da hat sich bei diesen dingen hat sich irgendeiner gedacht von da ist
bettel viel 22 42 das ist in der zukunft da sieht futuristisch aus
assets to make the mass more und jetzt hast du zumindest ein bisschen deckung was aber
nichts dran ändern dass das ding immer noch absolut flache ebene drumherum ist
ja und jetzt haben wir hier zwei kisten und einen truck stehen oder so abschlepper
rework debuting in season 2 also das würde ich nicht rework nennen leute das würde ich
nicht rework nennen das ist einfach auf den leeren maps ein paar 0815 standard
pops platziert die das bestimmt besser spielbar machen weil die map sind halt
so nicht spielbar aber das ist kein redesign ein redesign wäre für mich zum
beispiel wenn man sagt ok das haus ist weg dafür ist jetzt ein berg die
unterführung geht jetzt hier rein ins haus und solche dinger
and before we get to the rest of the story here is a quick word from today's sponsor i'm
pretty busy these days and wurde überhaupt mal eine map richtig nach
bettel field release gerne so gute frage
aber fällt mir nichts fällt mir jetzt gerade nicht ein
hätte mir nix ein gerade nö bestimmt wo ich jetzt nicht dran denke aber auch
möglich dass es nicht so war keine ahnung ja gut aber du musst es ja in
den älteren bettel feets die maps gar nicht grundlegend ändern weil die
formel ja auch zum größten teil ok waren
und im aktuellen teil sind die maps hat einfach scheiße
leon work all end up with little pockets of free time which i often spend playing
games on my phone or ipad and as a fan of shooter games and team
oh nein es ist sehr laut es ist das well on a mobile device but the good news is today's video is brought to you by
catalyst black neuer battleground shooter from so many people megacorp it just
das habe ich so i can bad if i need to bail from a match that's a blast through
several rounds the combat it can be at a tear which is cattle ja ok
objective oriented experience with limited tickets and passable on ios and
android devices think normalerweise normalerweise gucke ich mir die ads ja
immer an weil ich mir denke wir gucken uns die videos von und kann uns die ads
auch angucken aber das ding muss ich mir nicht anschauen
to super evil mega das ding sieht aus wie jedes mist handyspiel ja für sponsor
in this video now getting back to 20 42s
aufhandling changes dice have shared their plans for 20 42s game modes as well
32 player rush will be made a permanent mode is jetzt schon das einzig sinnvolle
der einzig sinnvolle spielmodus wird jetzt permanent war wahnsinn da ist
warfare 64 player breakthrough will be the standard now on and further
development on hazard zone has been halted
das haben aber schon gehört vor ein paar tagen
wisst ihr wisst ihr was das witzige ist an hazard zone jeder der hazard zone
gespielt hat sogar pre-release der hätte er hätte hätte es euch sagen
können dass hazard zone dead on a rifle ist so und das haben auch viele gesagt
ich glaube sogar die games da ich bin mir nicht sicher ob es moris war
irgendwie sogar im game star video wurde das gesagt dass das ding dead on a
rifle ist wahrscheinlich und warum konnte man das bei dais nicht sehen
wollte man sich so sehr einreden dass man hier was geiles entwickelt hat so ich
meine da ist hat richtig heftig an vielen stellen die augen vor der
realität verschlossen bei battlefield 20 42
ich habe mir sogar so getan am anfang als wird das eine art e-sport modus ob es
auch nur ein turnier gegeben hat für hazard so wahrscheinlich nicht das
einzige was es gab ihre komischen
es kommt in influenza events da ja
areas of the game in terms of new content season 1 will launch next month
according to dice this will mark the start of a year of new content
seh ich das richtig das ist alles was es mit season 1 gibt
ach nee ok breakthrough 64 players das macht es auch nicht besser
ich meine die spieleranzahl war keine gute idee aber das problem ist dass sie
die maps im hinterkopf gebaut haben mit 128 spielern und dafür sind die sind die
maps auch nicht gut aber diese welt mit 64 spielern nur nur marginal besser
und gerade die placements der der der basen und der flaggen in breakthrough ist
halt bescheuert ja es es ist auch total es ist auch ein ziemlich blödes system
so wie es gemacht ist weil du kannst beispielsweise breakthrough relativ easy
nicht überall aber auf gerade hier auf dieser map was es ist es die ray ich
kann mir das kann mir die map namen gar nicht bemerken die erste base hier auf
dieser map du kannst dich theoretisch mit 128 spielern einfach auf eine seite der
map campen und im prinzip hat keiner der attacker eine chance das ding einzunehmen
die können die andere flagge ruhig einnehmen das macht nichts und selbst
wenn die 128 spieler alle die entgegen werfen zum zum capturen dann rennst du
rüber und nimmst das andere ein das ist total sehr der spielmodus ist wirklich
hängen geblieben rüber rennen bedeutet übrigens fünf minuten rennen oder halt
respawn so season 1 gibt es new map new map nicht new maps new map map ein zahl
ein neuer specialist neue waffen neue fahrzeuge battle pass weekly missions
ja das haben dat alles portal featured experiences ok also im prinzip das ist
kein content das ist kein content und das ist kein content das einzige was
content ist ist das das das und das wobei man halt sagen muss dass der wirklich
interessante content tatsächlich der neue die neue map ist vielleicht der
specialist aber nachdem specialist eh kein mensch haben will
wer holt sich den battle pass die leute die sich die edition gekauft haben mit
dem battle pass dabei und es ist eine map sieben acht monate nach release man
they're committed to delivering es ist vorbei ist durch hat kein sinn
das aims to ship new maps specialist weapons and gadgets throughout the
seasons further revisions to the specialist appearance are also
vertreten along with a rework of the specialist system however details are
been met with mixed opinions from fans a dice community manager dann dann
dann reworked immer ich glaube nicht dass es da irgendwas zu riefer gibt außer
den graben raus zu hauen aus dem game wobei ich jetzt nie irgendwie jemand war
das erst mal so ja ich gebe zu dass battlefield und specialist nicht so
wirklich zusammenpasst die idee hinter der ganzen specialist geschichte da bin
ich gar nicht mal so abgeneigt man hätte es aber anders implementieren
müssen ja also man hätte beispielsweise faction style specialist machen müssen
also sprich man hätte die specialist nicht als das ist maria falck machen
müssen sondern man hätte sagen müssen ok es gibt 20 klassen zur auswahl und
dort gibt es dann faction basierte dinge typen die man auswählen kann oder so
weil so ist es halt relativ beknackt dass zehn maria falck gegen zehn maria
falck so unterschiedliche fraktion das ist bescheuert aber hätte man gesagt es
gibt ein irgendwie eine eine recon subklasse ich meine im prinzip sind
specialist ja subklassen wenn man so will subklassen der der der der alten
assault recon engineer was habe ich vergessen support so also sprich man
hätte sagen muss dass man spets das ist besser ein battlefield passt man hätte
sagen müssen es gibt jetzt die vier base klassen aber wir erweitern die auf fünf
subklassen pro base klassen es gibt fünf supporter fünf medics fünf
reckons fünf davon so und dann hätte man das faction basiert machen können
dann hätte man sagen können guck mal hier webstar ist beispielsweise für
diese faction oder hätte man sich einen anderen typ ausgedacht ist für die das
hätte natürlich mehr das muss man sagen mehr arbeit und mehr gehirn schmalz bei
dies erfordert aber dann hätte man das denke ich ganz gut einbauen können und
ich glaube das wäre tatsächlich eine gute erweiterung gewesen zu den
standardklassen mit pick dir was raus das hätte man nämlich auch deutlich
besser designen können so dass man nicht sagt hey ich mache mir einen sniper mit
unendlich munition und der sich selbst heilen kann und motion sensor hat und
so wobei das geht nicht zusammen aber solche komischen kombinationen hätte es
dann auch nicht gegeben also generell mehr fein ein bisschen mehr aufgespitterte
subklassen von den standardbattlefield klassen hätte glaube ich gar nicht so
schlecht funktioniert in battlefield ja man hat ansatzweise zuletzt gesehen in
bett company eins da hatte man zum beispiel noch noch mehr subklassen und
die haben sich auch teilweise schon ein bisschen überschnitten man hatte
beispielsweise
weiß heißt ja gar nicht classes wie heißt denn das da kids jetzt glaube ich
nicht
genau du hattest du hattest noch demolition dazu und man muss halt sagen
demolition war halt mit einer shotgun naja und also du hattest halt zwei die im
nahkampf ziemlich gut waren und du hattest auch zwei die gut sachen
zerstören konter hat den specialist mit c4 und das hat maschinen ganz und du
hattest den demolition mit der shotgun und dem rpg und das sind so dinge das
finde ich vom ansatz ja gar nicht schlecht hätte man das so gemacht hätte
man gesagt hey es gibt jetzt ist noch mal engineer aber von engineer gibt es
noch fünf subclasses ja einer mit was weiß ich ente haken das hätte man ja
alles machen können aber da nicht nicht ein ding übergreifen für alles das
hätte deutlich besser gepasst und ich weiß nicht das bis heute nicht was sie
sich dabei gedacht haben weil hätten sie mal wirklich battlefield begeisterte
leute gefragt oder hätten sie einfach mal sich angeguckt was ihre alten games
ebenso spielenswert gemacht hat dann hätten sie selbst auf die idee kommen
können oder man hätte es ihnen einfach sagen müssen dass das eine bescheuerte
idee ist und wenn man sich nur leute einlädt wenn überhaupt
die alles abfeiern dann wird das nix
der clarified on the games forms that the development update video confirmed
only one map is coming with season ja das wissen wir doch datamines had
previously suggested as many as die haben nur leute leute seriously
die haben nur eine map versprochen und es passiert genau das was ich gesagt habe
sie liefern das absolute minimum was sie machen müssen dass sie nicht
verklagt werden bei amis oder dass sie nicht dass man ihn nicht vorwerfen kann
sie hätten sich nicht daran gehalten was sie ganz klar in die in die
produktbeschreibung geschrieben haben sie hätten einen jetzt natürlich
überraschen können sie konnte was trinken
also sie hätten natürlich überraschen können und sagen hey sie ist worden es
gibt fünf neue maps aber warum da müssten sie geld und zeit und
entwicklungskosten da reinstecken nein die machen das absolut mindeste
ford maps might be added was die update nein das war doch so klar
the entire year it's just speculation until proven otherwise players are
understandably disappointed with the news considering past battlefields
gotten several new mass by the time 2042 das wusste man doch das ist doch also
wenn da jetzt noch enttäuscht ist und überrascht ist das kann ich nicht
verstehen das war so klar das habe ich quasi glaube ich schon in meinem ersten
wo ich mal ein bisschen so auf den putz gehauen habe dass ich so von dem game
denke video gesagt dass das spiel auf sparflammer betrieben wird dass ich das
nie wieder erholen wird und es ist so aber wer hätte wirklich was anderes
gedacht
du will get its first new map season 1 update notes that a by the way
viel vier hatte zu dem zeitpunkt glaube ich schon zwei dlc ist sekunde
komm was war ein bf3 dlc release bf4 dlc release dates
ja also hauptspiel release am man geil weiß man nicht
ja gibt es da gibt es da irgendwelche release dates oder so
keine ahnung dann weiß ich auch nicht
hier gibt es kein release date ich bin mir ziemlich sicher dass bf4 und
bf3 glaube ich auch schon zwei dlc hat zu dem zeitpunkt ich meine bf4 hatte
quasi die ersten dlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc
ddlc d ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc ddlc
perce
hi
Warfare 2 wird dieses Jahr am 28. Oktober eröffnen.
Die Pläne für das Spiel wurden auf Social Media eröffnet,
aber im Prinzip ist es immer noch das gleiche.
... aber im Prinzip ist es immer noch das gleiche.
Drei Pläne für das Spiel wurden auch online eröffnet,
dank der Datamining von Warzone's neuestes Saisonal Update.
Es gibt eine Standard-Cross-Gen-Bundle und Vault-Pläne.
Jede Pläne eröffnet die Spieler die unbekannte Open Beta,
aber die Vault-Pläne eröffnet zusätzliche Content.
Dies enthält die Season 1 der Battle Pass,
mehrere Operator-Packs, Blueprints für Waffen und Extras.
Also China Rising und dann am Juni.
Ok, ein DLC.
Second Assault war übrigens beim Release von der Xbox dabei.
Also guckt mal, die haben schon einen richtigen DLC gehabt
und der andere DLC ist quasi um die Ecke in 10 Tagen.
Also sagen wir mal so, Battlefield 4 hatte mehr oder weniger
zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt, bis die Season kommt, zwei DLCs.
Mit, glaube ich, acht Maps oder so.
Jedes hatte vier Maps, oder?
Ja, Four New Maps.
Four New Maps.
Also sprich, acht Maps.
Acht Maps in der Zeitpunkt, wo Battlefield 2042
das Service-Game eine Map bekommt.
So, One New Map, One Reader Release.
Ja gut, das Subreddit ist ja auch nicht sonderlich net zu DICE,
aber zu Recht, ja.
Ups, wollte ich gar nicht anklicken.
Ja, so ist es, so ist es, ja.
So sieht es aus.
Ist halt aktuell Unfähigkeit und Planlosigkeit in Person bei DICE.
Ja, das wundert mich nicht.
Das ist ja normal.
Solange die Verbreitung der Neue noch nicht so hoch ist,
dass es genug Kohle gibt,
gibt es das wahrscheinlich in abgespeckter Form,
wieder für die Alten und wundert mich nicht, ja.
Hab ich so gehockt.
Ja, die haben es...
Ich wollte gerade sagen, die haben es ja auch ein bisschen verkackt.
Ja, die haben ja auch diesen Service-Game-Traum gehabt
und es auch nicht auf die Reihe bekommen.
Aber wenigstens spielt sich das Game so,
wie man es vor einem Halo erwarten würde.
Ich weiß, da stimmen mir die ganzen Hardcore-Halo-Fans definitiv nicht zu.
Für die ist das das schlechteste Halo, was es hier gegeben hat.
Ich kann mir immer noch nicht vorstellen,
wie man Apex auf dem Smartphone gescheit spielen kann.
Aber es muss ja funktionieren,
weil sonst würden sich so viele Leute spielen.
Also irgendwie muss das ja steuerbar sein.
Habt ihr das gespielt? Habt ihr das gespielt?
Wie spielt sich Apex auf dem Touchscreen?
Ich kann es mir einfach nicht vorstellen, das auf dem Touchscreen zu spielen.
Ich hoffe, es kommt auf dem PC direkt raus.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht.
Oder weiß man da schon?
Es kommt erst ein Jahr später auf dem PC oder so.
Ja, das letzte God of War gibt es auf Steam.
Aber das ist ja das neue, das kommende.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob das auf dem PC...
Guck mal doch mal, PC.
Ja, man weiß es noch nicht.
Es kommt wahrscheinlich auch wieder ein Jahr später oder so.
Also ich denke, da wird was kommen, aber nicht so release.
Wir hoffen mal nicht, dass es von Amazon gemacht wird,
weil dann ist vorbei.
Ach ne, das ist...
Sind das nicht die Dishonored Typen?
Oder bringe ich das gerade durcheinander?
Irgendwie sieht God of War aus wie aus irgendeinem Comic.
Ich schwör's nicht.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, wenn die eine Playstation 5 Pro raushauen,
ist Konsole wirklich useless geworden.
Das war letzte Generation schon komplett bescheuert,
dass man einen Mid-Generation-Release gemacht hat.
Musste man aber, weil die letzte Konsolengeneration
wirklich mies war von Specs, als sie rausgekommen ist.
Die aktuelle Generation ist deutlich besser, aber macht man jetzt schon...
Ich mein, überlegt euch mal, was das bedeutet.
Die Leute versuchen händeringend seit...
Wann war Playstation Release? Vor einem Jahr?
Vor zwei Jahren, man muss sich mal überlegen, eineinhalb Jahre.
Die Leute versuchen händeringend...
Oder versuchen, quasi wie verrückt,
seine Hände an eine PS5 zu bekommen.
Dann haben die eine PS5, es gibt gar nicht mal so viele Games drauf.
Und jetzt kommen die mit einer PS5 Pro um die Ecke,
die quasi die PS5 mehr oder weniger obsolet macht,
so wie das bei der letzten Konsolengeneration war.
Da haben sie ja auch gesagt, ja, aber du kannst das immer noch auf den alten spielen.
Die alten Sachen waren halt mega beschissen versus die Pro-Variante.
Und wenn das wirklich der Move sein sollte,
ist es absolut useless geworden, sich Konsolen zu kaufen.
Der Vorteil von Konsolen war immer, du konntest dir das Ding kaufen
und dann wusstest du, du hast für die nächsten 5-6 Jahre
die gleiche Experience wie alle anderen auch
und die Spiele so, wie sie der Hersteller sich gedacht und entworfen hat.
Wenn man jetzt quasi auf einen Schlag
die komplette 1. PS5-Generation useless macht
oder obsolet macht, wäre ein äußerst bescheuerter Move.
Ach, das sind die mit den Deponia-Spielen.
War mal, wie hießen denn die, die, die Dishonored?
Entwickler nochmal.
Arkane Studios.
Wie komme ich auf Dishonored, Alter?
Keine Ahnung, das war Arkane natürlich.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Das habe ich auch gehört.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich bei diesen FIFA-Dingern immer mega lustig finde?
Die zeigen immer, was für geile Technologie angeblich in FIFA steckt,
so von ihrem Motion-Capturing und was sie da Geiles machen
und trotzdem sieht FIFA immer S aus.
Die zeigen immer, was für geile Technologie angeblich in FIFA steckt,
so von ihrem Motion-Capturing und was sie da Geiles machen
und trotzdem sieht FIFA immer S aus.
Und trotzdem sieht FIFA immer S aus, ja.
Das sieht halt einfach, das sieht halt einfach nicht gut aus.
Und auch Animationstechnik und sonst was,
für das, dass sie so nach dem Motto immer,
guck dir, wir haben die geilste Technik auf der Welt.
Ich weiß nicht, da hat der Uncharted drei bessere Animationen,
ne, äh, doch drei.
Was ist eigentlich, warum sind eigentlich so viele Spiele-Umsetzungen in letzter Zeit erschienen
und warum sind die alle Müll?
Die Halo-Serie, hab ich gar nicht, hab ich mir erst gar nicht angegeben,
soll ja wohl der noch nicht mal ein müde Abklatsch von Halo sein,
sondern quasi die komplette Demontage von Halo im Endeffekt.
Zumindest,
die ganze Demontage von Halo,
den ganzen Demontage von Halo,
die ganz nah estoy royalty &
gameplay.
That's all the stuffhh
Willkommen zu
et
be
depend
aber wenn ich das mal so
so das allgemeine stimmungsbild was ich auch der war kraft filmen fand ich auch nicht gut die hatten ein paar coole sachen drinne wie dass sie
beispielsweise
Einmal jemand geschiebt haben aber ansonsten war aber das aber der war für mich auch schon keine ahnung zehn jahre locker locker her
Ansonsten ja die lol serie soll wirklich gut sein witcher ganz ehrlich
Also
Ich fand es nicht sonderlich gut das ist ok
Das ist in ordnung gewesen die also die die erste staffel war in ordnung zum größten teil
aber sehr wie soll ich sagen
Du hattest so den eindruck als
Kümmern sie sich selbst nicht rum was sie eine folge vorher gemacht haben also das war sehr inkonsistent und ich weiß ich also mir hat es
Es war passabel ja
Die zweite staffel werde ich mir nicht mehr angucken
Diese detaillen wurden während eines Investorenbriefings veröffentlicht. Die amazon gott of war serie wird andere playstation exklusivs, wie unschattet
Chat chat und wer unschattet gespielt hat wer ist besser chloe oder elena
Das muss ich jetzt von euch wissen chat
Der erste sagt wahrscheinlich haben die spiel kaum jemand gespielt oder kann sich noch an die characters erinnern also ich muss sagen eindeutig elena für meinen geschmack
The last of us in ghost of tsushima, which are also getting tv shows or movies
However, there's no mention in the last of us
In dem
Es sieht so aus, dass viele Entwickler wieder nach Prag gekommen sind, um die Entwicklung zu beenden.
Stalker 2 hatte eigentlich einen Dezember-Launch-Date, aber die Fans erlauben, dass die Dinge
wegen dieser Verstöße zurückkehren werden.
Das ist mal ein Verschiebungstermin, den ich auch wirklich nachvollziehen kann.
Wenn ein Entwickler sagt, Leute, wir werden beschossen, wir können nicht weiterentwickeln.
Das verstehe ich, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Da kann ich das nachvollziehen, warum man das verschiebt.
Bevor wir zum letzten Thema kommen, lassen Sie uns wissen, was Sie von Update 4.1 für Battlefield 2042 denken.
Und ob Sie überhaupt großartig den Kopf haben, jetzt mal ehrlich, belegt euch mal, ihr seid in einem Kriegsgebiet und ihr müsst dann quasi kreative Spielentwicklungsleistungen vollbringen, stelle ich mir auch schwierig vor.
Wenn du mitbekommst, so nach dem Motto, irgendwelche Leute sind gestorben, die du kennst, und das war als Spielentwicklung, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das auch psychisch nicht so easy ist.
Moment, Moment.
Ich will gucken, ob er das sagt, was ich predictiert habe.
Ich wusste es, der sagt immer den gleichen Shit am Ende, immer, immer, Alter, immer, immer das gleiche.
Oh, ich wusste nicht, wie der Typ aus Death Stranding heißt, ich habe die ganze Zeit im Hinterkopf gedacht, das wäre der Typ aus Death Stranding, aber nein, das ist ja der Schauspieler mit dem Namen.
Und das war es für diese Woche im Gaming, wie immer Leute, danke für das Zuschauen, und wir sehen uns nächste Woche.
Oder hat es keiner gespielt?
Ein Ende, das verwirrt, ja gut, das ist ja normal.
Ich habe das Ende nicht verstanden, okay, das ist glaube ich ein Feature bei diesen Games.
Okay, was haben wir denn als was, können wir uns als nächstes angucken.
Normalerweise gucke ich mir solche Videos nicht an, weil diese Videos, das wurde mir vorhin empfohlen auf YouTube, weil diese Videos im Prinzip immer G-Bates sind.
Und man eigentlich sich schon denken kann, was passiert.
Also ich predicte jetzt mal was, und dann skippen wir ein bisschen durch das Video, ich predicte mal was.
Der Typ hat nicht irgendwie Probleme mit seinem iPhone oder sonst was, der hat einen Kabel, wo irgendwelche Controller drin sind, die auf seinem PC Dinger machen oder auf seinem Mac.
Also was weiß ich, zum Beispiel ein Ladekabel, was sich als Tastatur anmeldet am Rechner und dann irgendwelche Befehle ausführt oder sowas.
Und mal gucken, ob ich Recht habe, solche Videos sind immer richtig G-Bate.
Okay, das halte ich nicht aus, Leute die instant schreien. Okay, da schreit mich, ich hatte das Video mal zu laut.
These cables into your computer. It might look like a normal, innocent iPhone charging cable, but it is actually a modified variant of it.
The power to hijack your devices, steal every last bit of your personal info and then self destruct to not leave a trace behind.
So I've got two iPhone cables here, one is real, one is fake.
Alter, woher willst du das sehen? Das siehst du dem Ding doch von außen nicht an. Oh Gott, ne ne ne, das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Natürlich, natürlich. Der hat es sicherlich nicht realist.
Der sitzt einfach, die werden gefilmt, er sitzt gegenüber, greift über den Schreibtisch, das hat er bestimmt nicht realist, dass da gerade da was reinsteckt in seinen Monitor.
Garantiert hat er das nicht realist. Das ist dem He doesn't know, he lacked critical information, er wusste das garantiert nicht.
And we're in. So did that just literally pop out the blue? Ja gut, das ist wie ich gesagt hab, das ist ein USB-Kabel, was ich als Tastatur anmeldet.
Did you notice me plugging it into your computer? Aha, nein, überhaupt nicht gefaked.
So that I could actually put the USB-Stick in while you couldn't see what was going on. And you had no idea, right? No idea. Words.
And so, well there clearly is a fun side to all this.
Das funktioniert normalerweise etwas anders, ja. Aber gut, also gibt's ja verschiedene Varianten, klar kannst du auch, wenn du irgendwie sagst, hey, ich muss mal bei euch sauber machen, dann irgendwie die USB-Sticks anschließen.
Aber was es auch schon oft gegeben hat, ist, wir lernen einfach mal ein zwanziger Pack USB-Sticks auf dem Parkplatz aus, mal gucken, was so passiert.
By the way, das ist übrigens auch überhaupt nichts neues, ja. Also, USB-Geräte, die sich als Tastatur anmelden, ist quasi eines der ältesten Tricks in dieser Richtung, was es gibt.
Ich will das nicht gucken, das geht mir auf den Sack. Ich weiß nicht, warum das geht mir auf den Sack.
So, next. Was können wir uns sonst anschauen?
Es, ja, also das ist überhaupt auch gar nichts besonderes irgendwie. Mein gut, der 0815 YouTube-User, der hat wahrscheinlich von der Existenz solcher Sachen noch nichts gewusst. Kann ich verstehen. Aber das jetzt irgendwie als super, wie soll man sagen, als super krass noch nie dagewesene neue Hacker-Methode zu verkaufen, ist ein bisschen an der Realität vorbei.
Okay.
Was für ein Ding? Okay, für dieses Wort bin ich zu Boomer, das müsst ihr mir erklären. Was ist der Insimodus?
Kann man danach googeln?
Inscope-Modus. Ah, der Inscope-Modus.
Insolvenz-Modus. Ah, der Inscope-Modus könnte ich mir auch gut vorstellen.
Insolvenz, aha.
Insolvenz-Modus.
Wegen ApoRed?
Was hat er denn wieder gemacht? Ich blick nicht durch, was auf YouTube passiert.
Wie kann der Dude, seriously, wie kann der, okay, wahrscheinlich sind irgendwelche seiner Firmen pleitegegangen oder so, aber nicht er selbst.
Ich mein, wie kannst du pleitegehen mit so einer Reichweite und so viel Einnahmequellen?
Insolvenzbetrug von ApoRed. Sagt ihr das jetzt oder ist das, hat das irgendjemand auch wirklich mal bestätigt, ja?
Aha, aha.
Ab hier. ApoRed und der Insimodus. Was the fuck, Alter?
Okay, Sekund, das war schwer, den Ausstellungen muss ich mir zumindest mal kurz angucken.
Kritische Hase sozusagen, ja.
Die entscheidende Stelle hier. Ich muss noch mal machen, dass ihr das auch.
Wenn man halt einfach den Insimodus aktiviert, also wenn man einfach.
Den was?
Dann ist es halt nicht der Fall. Dann könnt ihr schön trotzdem im Ausland schön eure Geschäfte anmelden, alles darüber laufen lassen und seid einfach delegat.
Das ist halt der Fall, wenn man von sich selbst denkt, man ist zu schlau für diese Welt.
Dann wird man irgendwann zu leichtsinnig.
Die ganzen deutschen Kopfschmerzgeschichten einfach los und.
Ja, also, das muss ich auf die Zunge zergehen lassen.
Er sagt jetzt hier, ich mach Privatinsolvenz, hab den Insimodus aktiviert.
Das war ja das, was die Eingangs-Message war von Simon Unge an mich.
Und von da an ist mir alles ein Problem los.
Der Insimodus.
Die Nummer schlechthin.
Von da an gar keine Probleme mehr.
Wir haben den Insimodus.
Die haben die Knete.
Mal gucken, ob er vom Datenleck betroffen ist.
Da braucht man nicht einen Insimodus, sondern würde so noch die 1000 Euro bekommen.
Aber Spaß beiseite.
Geht das so einfach?
Kann man einfach Insolvenzantrag stellen, um im Ausland dann selbstständig zu arbeiten.
Und in Deutschland muss man dann keine Steuern zahlen, weil alles natürlich futsch ist,
weil ich euch ja gerade so schön erläutert habe, wie das abläuft mit so einem Insolvenzverfahren.
Naja, es ist also davon auszugehen, dass ApoRed jetzt schon, um überhaupt im Ausland
Geschäfte machen zu können, einen Teil seines Vermögens ins Ausland gebracht hat.
Denn wenn er mit Null startet, kann er natürlich auch keine Geschäfte machen.
Das ist übrigens auch etwas, was wir sagen.
Der Insimodus.
Okay, verstanden, verstanden.
Tja, das ist wie gesagt, wenn du irgendwann denkst, du bist so clever,
dass du sie alle outplayed hast und das dann auch noch öffentlich im Video erzählst.
Das heißt natürlich...
Ist geil, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Der Insimodus.
Gut, ich mein, ich kenn's aus meiner Familie.
Ich hab euch ja die Story schon mal erzählt.
Da gibt's auch jemand, der der Meinung war, er kann das Steuersystem austribbeln.
Hat nicht so gut funktioniert.
Wobei das noch die ganze Ecke vor YouTube und sonst was war.
Sonst wäre er wahrscheinlich auch YouTube-Influencer geworden damals.
Ja, also bei Steuersachen verstehen die wirklich keinen Spaß.
Da hast du gelitten.
Deswegen mach ich das auch immer alles super ordentlich.
Mit Steuerberater und allem.
Ich hasse zwar Steuerkram, ich mach das überhaupt gar nicht null.
Ich mach das gar nicht gerne.
Ich kann das überhaupt nicht ab.
Deswegen lass ich das auch seit ich hier die Firma hab,
das mit dem Steuerberater machen.
Aber ich mach's immer ordentlich, weil ich keinen Bock hab auf irgendwelchen Stress in der Richtung.
Und ich möchte auch nicht den Insimodus aktivieren müssen, ja.
Oh Mann.
Okay, jetzt weiß ich, was der Insimodus ist, alles klar.
Ist schon ein bisschen hängen geblieben, aber gut.
Ich sag' jetzt dazu nichts mehr.
Ich wollte grad noch was sagen.
Aber ich hab' mich da ja null damit beschäftigt.
Ich hab' keine Ahnung was da wirklich gelaufen ist.
Aber ich find's schon schon
Zeit um' was zur B Euro zu machen.
Wir müssen st życia.
gelaufen ist. Aber ich finde es schon fragwürdig irgendwo, weil das sind ja nur Leute, die
nicht irgendwie am Hungertuch nagen eigentlich. Du hast so viele Möglichkeiten, gerade als
größerer Influencer. Es ist ja in diesem Bereich quasi noch mehr als in vielen anderen
Bereichen so. Umso größer du bist, umso größere Sachen ziehst du an und wirst wahrscheinlich
noch größer. Das ist gerade im Influencer-Bereich krasse Geschichte. Der hat da so viele Möglichkeiten,
aber trotzdem versuchen sie sich ja irgendwie vorzudrücken. Der 0815 Zuschauer donatet
da noch sein Taschengeld und sowas. Das werde ich nicht nachvollziehen können. Na ja gut,
also gucken wir mal weiter. Was haben wir denn sonst noch zu bieten hier? Chatkontrolle
bepowert by EU. What happens when you click accept all? Naja, das was da steht, nur dass
ich nicht genau weiß, was ich akzeptiere. Ganz davon abgesehen, es ist vollkommen egal,
wenn ich die passenden Browser Addons habe. Cookies sind ja pauschal erstmal nichts Schlimmes.
Cookies sind seit Jahren schon immer, die 0815 Internetnoobs wissen, dass es Cookies
gibt. Die wissen nicht so genau, was Cookies sind, aber die wissen, dass es Cookies gibt.
Und viele denken Cookies sind was ganz furchtbar böses, was ja pauschal so nicht stimmt. Ich
habe das Video gerade zusammengefasst, ja siehst du. Was? How loud can a sound get? Hey there.
Das habe ich schon mal geguckt. Lass mal überlegen, wie laut kann ein Sound werden? Was ist wenn
sich das schneller als Schallgeschwindigkeit ausdehnt? Ist es da noch ein Sound? Keine
Ahnung. Es ist eher so eine Druckwelle oder so. Also unendlich kann so gut wie nix werden.
Ich mein, man denkt das bei vielen Sachen, weil es sehr hoch ist. Zum Beispiel dachte
ich auch früher in der Schule noch, ja gut, minus 273 Grad Celsius ist Schluss. Das ist
ja im Prinzip richtig, aber ich dachte immer nach oben hin gibt es quasi kein Limit. Das
stimmt aber nicht. Es gibt eine theoretische Maximaltemperatur und es gibt fast nix, was
unendlich in dem Sinn werden kann. Aber manchen Sachen sind wir uns noch nicht so ganz sicher.
Aber es gibt wenig, was wirklich unendlich ist. Also es gibt wenig, was unendlich ist
und es gibt auch wenig, was komplett Null ist.
Das ist nicht der Überschall, das ist das Flugzeug, was Überschall fliegt. Aber die
Dinger machen ja auch Krach und keine Ahnung, da hab ich mir noch keine Gedanken zu gemacht.
Jetzt gucken wir gleich das Video an. Die Winnera Test Version. Also, ne Moment, wo sind
wir stehen geblieben? Wo ist das Video? Hau laut das Cockade, das gucken wir uns jetzt
an. Bisschen Bildung im Stream schadet nicht. Im Zweifelsfall eine Sache, Infinite ist es
bestimmt nicht. Aber es ist wahrscheinlich ziemlich laut.
Okay, so die Antwort ist ziemlich lang. Und in meiner Meinung, ohne hyperbolisch zu sein,
denke ich, dass die Antwort total verrückt ist. Und für einige meiner Zuschauer wird dein
Sicht der Realität für den Rest deiner Leben. Okay, er challenge unsere Reality und View
of Life in zwölf Minuten, jetzt bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Okay, so die Antwort ist ziemlich lang. Und in meiner Meinung, ohne hyperbolisch zu sein,
können wir in einer Realität mit sehr komplizierten Spektren leben. Z.B. ist es 62 F, 16,666 C
oder 290 K outside right now, aber mein Gehirn sagt einfach, es ist chillig. Hier ist etwas,
was du wahrscheinlich in der Schulzeit gelernt hast und komplett vergessen hast. Wie groß
ist der Sonn? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, aber die Sonne ist ziemlich groß. Die Sonne ist so groß und massereich,
dass quasi der Rest, also unser Sonnensystem besteht irgendwie aus 99% Sonne und 1% Rest
oder so. Also die ist schon recht groß und auch massive. Aber ich meine, muss sie ja
auch sein, sonst würde das ja mit der ganzen Fusion nicht funktionieren. Alles klar. Was
genau hat das jetzt nochmal kurz mit dem Sonn zu tun? Miles? Kann man das vielleicht in
der gescheiten Einheit machen? So was wie Kilometer z.B. oder so?
Das ist der polarische oder äquatorische Diameter.
Fußballfelder.
Na Dezibel an sich? Dezibel an sich ist doch eigentlich nur eine Skala, oder?
Das hat jetzt erstmal, soweit ich weiß, nicht wirklich was mit Sound zu tun, oder? Ich meine,
da wird es zum größten Teil verwendet.
So lasst uns alles ein bisschen anders befreien. Wenn ich meine Hände klappe, drücke ich
mir
auf.
These pressure waves also vibrate tiny hairs in my inner ear and various tones or time between compressions and rarefactions are detected by hairs in different parts of this complex passage.
It isn't until my brain is involved that these pressure waves turn into sound, as that's what's doing the translation.
This makes sound a very subjective thing, so the answer to our original question is going to depend on the individual.
But there still is a way that we measure this.
I'm sure you've heard of decibels. That's how we measure how loud something is.
Ja, decibel ist da eine Einheit bzw. Skala, mit der ich nicht klarkomme, weil die so komisch skaliert.
Das ist irgendwie immer...
...irgendwie, ja...
...nicht in Zehnerpotensie, das ist das so ganz komisches Verhältnis irgendwie.
Also, sprich, wenn du diese hier irgendwie dB, Sound, Examples...
Ja, da hast du ja hier diese...
Ja, sowas hier, guck. Zum Beispiel Jet Take Off 150 und ein ruhiger Raum ist...
...hier in der Bibliothek ist es 40.
Also, da würdest du quasi denken, warum ist denn ein Donner irgendwie...
...wäre dreimal lauter als es in einer ruhigen Bibliothek ist, also ist es ja gar nicht.
Das ist so ein ganz komisches Verhältnis, wie das anstreikt.
Geht irgendwie so logarithmisch, ja, genau.
Deswegen habe ich da immer Schwierigkeiten, wenn ich solche Skalen sehe, das...
...so im Kopf zu greifen, wo ich sage, hey...
...ja, das ist so und so viel mal lauter, das stimmt ja gar nicht.
6 dB Unterschied ist doppelt so, genau so was ist und das ist nicht sonderlich intuitiv.
Siehst du, 60 ist doppelt so laut wie 50.
Da gibt es doch bestimmt irgendwelche genormten Mikrofone und Gedürfnis.
Jetzt wird es aber auswärts.
Ich habe gerade rechtlich schnell gezählt, also zählt.
Gut, das lag daran, weil sich das immer neu verteilt hat.
Ja, deswegen wird ja auch überall, außer bei den Amis, Distanz z.B. in Kilometern gemessen und nicht in Feet und Miles und das Zeug.
Die kleinste Stelle auf der Erde ist ein anechoic Zimmer und im Inneren ist die Abwechslung bei 9,4 dB.
So, zurück zu der Frage. Wir können rechtlich sagen, dass Delia Volumen, wie in Dezibel, und wir können auch rechtlich sagen, dass sie über Wasser auf der Erde spricht.
Audiovolumen ist nicht unbedingt limited, aber durch wie viel Druck man in einer Atmosphäre krammen kann, bevor man einen Vakuum startet.
Und das passiert bei ca. 194 dB. An dem Punkt würde die Waveform physisch starten zu gestörten.
Und wenn ich so laut sprechen könnte, und man das Volumen hören könnte, als die Druck erhöhte, würde meine Stimme wahrscheinlich so aussehen.
Aber wenn meine Stimme bei ca. 194 dB war, hätte man viel größere Probleme.
Aaand in ca. doch 150 dB, würde das bei mir sehr schwer Zeug werden.
Ist da gut?
Anzeige ist raus, ja.
Habt ihr jetzt auch alle Brain-Injury?
Ich erinnere mich an ein Flugzeug.
Das war die 3. Valkanik-Explosion über 3000 Meilen in Indonesien.
Es war der lauteste Geräusch in der Geschichte.
Die Druckwaffen, die aus dieser Explosion geradiert wurden, wurden vier verschiedene Zeiten entdeckt.
Und das muss auch ziemlich laut gewesen sein.
Und wie laut war das?
Aha.
Oma 0818, danke für das Zappen.
Das Bromwale.
Das habe ich mich noch nie gefragt, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Danke, Z.
So, okay, wissen wir jetzt mehr als vorher?
Sie betet, ja. Hat aber gereicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sich jetzt meine Weltanschauung geändert hat, wie am Anfang behauptet, aber immerhin habe ich das Video durchgehalten.
Nicht wie das davor.
Ja, warum nicht?
Das witzige ist, ich habe heute morgen auf dem Handy was gelesen, dass Linux FX wohl User-Daten öffentlich in einer MySQL-Datenbank im Internet hatte.
Pass mal auf.
Sie waren so schlau und haben Hardcoded in irgendeinem Binary, was damit ausgeliefert wird, haben die ihren Host, ihren Username und ihr Passwort und ihr Datenbanknamen reinencoded.
Also man muss sich das mal vorstellen, wie amateurhaft es ist. Die haben allen Ernstes ein Programm mitgeliefert, was sich zu einer public MySQL-Datenbank verbindet.
Die haben keine Web-AP davor, um das zu machen. Nein, die haben eine Public-Datenbank im Internet mit Credentials, die quasi im Klartext aus einem Binary auslesbar sind.
Und um das ganze noch zu toppen, dieses Binary von Linux FX zum Betriebssystem registrieren ist in Gambas programmiert. Wisst ihr was Gambas ist? Das ist ein Wishill Basic-Klon.
Ich habe keinen Plastenschimmer, warum man überhaupt irgendwas programmiert in Wishill Basic.
Aber okay.
Was bedeutet das für einen End-User? Das bedeutet, wenn du Linux FX verwendet hast, diese Linux-Distribution hier, dich da drin registriert hast, dass dann quasi jeder im Internet, der so diese Passwörter hier mal ausgelesen hat, deine E-Mail-Adresse, deine Seriennummer und Zeugs auslesen kann.
Also die E-Mail-Adresse ist wahrscheinlich das Blödeste, was man da auslesen kann.
Das muss man sich echt mal vorstellen.
Wir gucken uns mal nur das Fazit an, weil das Video ist zu einer Zeit aufgenommen, wo man auch nicht wusste, dass die Benutzerdaten geleakt haben.
Nur, wir gucken uns mal nur das Fazit an.
By the way, ich verstehe den Sinn übrigens nicht davon. Jaja, du musstest dich registrieren und bezahlen. Naja gut, das wundern sich ja irgendwelche Microsoft-Umsteiger nicht. Es ist meiner Ansicht nach übrigens die vollkommen falsche Art und Weise, die Leute zum Linux-Benutzen zu bekommen. Wenn man Linux macht wie Windows, erzeugt das den Eindruck, als könnte man das auch benutzen wie Windows, sonst kann man ja unterm Strich nicht.
Manchen Benchmarks Windows sogar schlagen kann, teilweise sogar in Emulation. Das beantwortet für mich sogar die Frage ganz gut, warum man überhaupt LinuxFX nutzen sollte.
Gar nicht.
Für Windows-Umsteiger könnte das System eine kurzfristige Alternative sein zu Windows 11, insbesondere dann, wenn Microsoft auf älterer, schwächerer und nicht mehr unterstützter Hardware die Alternative zu Windows 11 mag vielleicht für manche Leute Linux sein, vielleicht, aber bestimmt kein Linux im Windows-Skin, die Updates abtritt.
Dieses Thinkpad ist wahrscheinlich das perfekte Szenario für LinuxFX und für jemanden, der nur Windows benutzt hat, wird einem das ähnliche Design definitiv den Umstieg erleichtern.
Glaube ich nicht. Glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube, das ist eine, weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, sowas, was auf den ersten Blick gut aussieht, aber sich im Nachhinein als Nachteil rausstellt. Gibt's irgendein cooles Wort für fällt mir grad nicht ein.
Ähm, Plender? Schrotz. Sus. Es ist Sus, genau. Oder Sass, wie das in Videos vor der Tage schaut. Es ist höchst Sass, genau.
Also, man denkt erstmal, oh cool, dann erkenne ich ja die Sachen wieder. Ähm, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass sich dahinter im Zweifelsfall unter Linux ganz andere Sachen verbergen und ich mit der Einstellung rangehe, ach, das ist ja wie Windows. Aber das ist es schon zwei Zentimeter unter der Oberfläche nicht mehr.
Und wer zum Teufel hat Microsoft Edge da standardmäßig drauf?
Nö. Ich meine zum Beispiel, was mit Nix nicht aktiviert steht. Nur weil das Microsoft macht, ist es doch gerade eines der Vorteile, dass man das unter Linux nicht braucht.
Ich nicht.
Ich kann mir nicht sagen, die Arbeit, die man reinsteckt, klar, das kann man schon irgendwie anerkennen, aber ich finde es absolut nicht sinnvoll, sowas zu verwenden.
Ich finde es nicht sinnvoll, sowas zu verwenden.
Was ist denn eigentlich unten drunter? Habt ihr eine Ahnung, was da unten drunter ist? Also ich hätte jetzt drauf getippt, dass es irgendeinen GNOME Reskin, muss es aber nicht sein. KDE, ja.
Stimmt, Dolphin, ja dann ist es höchstwahrscheinlich KDE.
Das stimmt, gut, dass er das in dem Video schon sagt. Und weil jetzt ist ja auch rausgekommen, wir haben eine öffentliche Datenbank im Internet mit Registrierungsdaten der Leute.
Sehe ich ganz genau so, ja.
Und das war es aber schon von mir und von unserem Review von LinuxFX, einer Linux-Distribution, die geschaffen wurde, um Windows zu imitieren und die das für meinen Geschmack sogar ein Stückchen zu gut macht.
Wenn ihr noch weitere Tipps, Tricks und Details rund um Windows 11 sehen wollt, dann gebt mir gerne ein Abo und auch ein Like auf dieses Video, denn jede Unterstützung hilft.
Ich sag vielen Dank fürs Zusehen, tschüss und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
PainsChamp
Die aktuellen Probleme bei den Kartenlesern sollen mit einem Zertifikatsfehler zusammenhängen.
Aber das ist eigentlich eher ein Gag. Warum es so viele Sterne hat, keine Ahnung. Revert, okay, aber allein schon die Commit-Messages sind doch Satire, oder? Revert, Revert, Merge, Merge, Main into Main.
Also sprich, der hat irgendwann mal Main into Main gemerged. Das passiert normalerweise nur, wenn man vorne nicht ordentlich rebaste. Dann hat er das revertet und dann hat er das revert revertet. Exzellent. Das sind schon quasi Sus-Sus-Commits.
PainsChamp
Der hat aber eine lange gesucht, bis der irgendwo in den Tiefen von Unicode ein Zeichen aus wahrscheinlich irgendeiner antiken Sprache gefunden hat, was entfernt aussieht wie so ein Among Us Character.
Was ist das für ein Zeichen? Das muss ich jetzt mal nachgucken.
Sinhala Letter Kantayanasikayaya. Alles klar. Was für ein Ding.
Singhalesische Sprache ist die Sprache der Singhalesen. Der größte ethnischen Gruppe Sri Lankas. Alles klar.
Jetzt weiß man Bescheid.
Ja, die hätten auch nicht gedacht, dass einer ihre Buchstaben mal so weit Verbreitung findet im Internet. Guck mal, das gibt es schon seit Unicode Version 3 von 1999.
Hast du echt schon mal gehört? Ich nicht. Noch nie.
UMTS 3. Als das Internet aufs Handy kam. Focus Reportage. Okay, komm, das geben wir uns jetzt. Da kann ich sagen, Jungs, ich war dabei, um mal wieder klarzustellen, wie boomer ich eigentlich bin.
2003, da war ich 19. Ja, 19. 19 war ich da.
Was zum... Warum müssen Leute über sowas öffentlich Videos machen? Okay, ich weiß, wenn es den Leuten hilft, okay. Ich würde sowas nicht öffentlich auf YouTube freitreten.
Und mir ging es auch schon schlecht nach Trennung, aber ich wäre nie auf die Idee gekommen, ein YouTube Video drüber zu machen. Aber okay. Egal. Soll jeder machen, was er will.
Also, als das Internet auf das Handy kam, dann zeig mal her. Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt wieder feststellen werden? Wie letztes Millennium die Leute noch 2003 ausgesehen haben.
2003 war quasi noch 90er. Startfrei für den ersten UMTS Praxistest. Wir rüsten die Düsseldorferinnen Christina Peter und Nora Felgenhauer mit einem der brandneuen Handys aus. Bei einem Stadtbummel sollen die beiden ausprobieren, was die dritte Generation der Mobilfunknetze alles kann.
Leute, wir sind nicht weit gekommen, oder? Wenn das die dritte Generation ist und jetzt sind wir bei 5G. Das hat aber lang gebraucht, zwei Generationen jetzt irgendwie einfach mal 20 Jahre.
Ab wann wurde das eigentlich bezahlbar? Also ernsthaft, ich bin der Meinung, mobiles Internet so wirklich gute Tarife gibt seit drei Jahren oder so. Es ist es ist lang her. Es ist noch nicht lang her, dass es wirklich Tarife gibt, wo ich sage Ja, das ist volumentechnisch okay.
Und das ist preislich okay, drei maximal vier Jahre. Davor davor waren alle Internet Tarife, also Mobilfunk Tarife, kürze.
Und bis heute nicht, bis heute nicht auf der Bahnstrecke, wo ich morgens fahre an zwei Stellen. Okay, UMTS ist ja mittlerweile quasi weg.
Hallo, ich sehe dich ja, das sieht super aus. Damals dachte man Videotelefonie ist die Zukunft. Heute haben wir die Technik für Videotelefonie und niemand verwendet Videotelefonie, weil Videotelefonie Paints Champ ist.
Die hätten mal die Bildschirme filmen sollen, weil wisst ihr was die in Wirklichkeit sehen? Irgendein 0,5 FPS Bild und ihr Datentarif ist leer danach oder so teuer die Minute, dass es sich nicht lohnt.
Ja, sicher. Die Auflösung ist noch sehr grob und auch das Bild hat ungefähr 0,5 FPS. Immerhin, es ist live. Übrigens, das lag weniger an UMTS damals, würde ich jetzt einfach mal behaupten, sondern eher an der schlechten Hardware der Handys.
Ich will die Leute gar nicht sehen. Ganz ehrlich, mir ist am liebsten auch in Teams, ich sehe die Leute nicht und die wollen mich nicht sehen. Also das liegt eher an der schlechten Hardware der Handys.
Also ich meine, UMTS hat wie viel? Standardmäßig 3G, Bandbreite. So schlecht ist das gar nicht gewesen. Ja? Ja. 384. Damit kann man durchaus, gerade in dieser Größe auf diesen Handys, damit kannst du durchaus ein relativ gutes Video übertragen.
Also wir reden jetzt nicht von 4K und sonst was, sondern was angemessen für die kleinen Menschen. Aber die Hardware der Handys war damals so schlecht.
Welches Protokoll würde ich dafür benutzen? Also das Video selbst ist definitiv nicht H.264. Das gab es damals noch nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was für ein Video-Codec damals für diese Dinger verwendet wurde. Keine Ahnung.
Das bin ich komplett überfragt.
Die dazu passenden Telefone hat Michael Suck von der Fachzeitschrift Chip auf Herz und Nieren geprüft. Im Handel erhältlich sich...
Wisst ihr, so sah es damals noch bei Zeitschriftredaktionen aus. Die wussten, was sie machen. Das war noch richtige Hardware. Ich meine, ich fand die Chip nie sonderlich geil, muss ich sagen. Und heute kannst du Chip aber komplett knicken.
Chip ist heute so eine Webseite, die 10 krasse Registry-Hacks, wobei das ist auch schon out. Chip ist heute merkwürdig, genauso wie PC-Welt oder sowas. Die CT ist noch für normale Leser eigentlich das beste.
Wobei ich auch, wie gesagt, ich habe ewig ein CT, aber ich lese die eigentlich kaum noch. Naja, zumindest so sah es damals aus. Da hat es ja noch so schöne Sachen wie IDE-Anschlüsse auf Mainboards oder AGP-Grafika. Soundkarten hat es damals noch.
Was auch witzig war, das sind ja so Boxen. Zu der damaligen Zeit war es total modern, dass man am Rechner irgendwelche Lautsprecher hatte, wo dann dran stand irgendwie 2000 Watt Aktivbox und das Ding war halt so ein paar Zentimeter großes weißes Plastik-Ding. 2000 Watt, Alter! Das Ding schmilzt!
Das fliegt auseinander und verletzt dich dabei. Die haben da einfach irgendwas draufgeschrieben, die Hersteller. Was gibt es eigentlich für richtige Fachzeitschriften?
Gut, du hast so für die 0815 Sachen die CT, dann hast du noch die IX und ansonsten ehrlich gesagt eigentlich nur Online-Zeug. Mir fällt in Zeitschriften wenig ein.
Das sind derzeit nur zwei Geräte. Das Nokia 7600 für rund 280 Euro mit T-Mobile-Vertrag.
Was soll ich das mal auf der Zunge zergehen? 200 Euro für ein High-End-Handy. Für 280 Euro kriegst du heute einen China-Chinesen-Android. Was sagt?
Und das Samsung Z105 für knapp 300 Euro mit Vertrag bei Wodafone. Was zum Teufel ist das für eine beknackte Tastatur, Alter? Wie soll man da wählen?
Das Samsung sieht aus wie ein ganz normales Club-Handy. Ich kann es auch genauso bedienen, UMTS hin oder her. Größter Unterschied, diese Digitalkamera kann ich nur zum Knipsen nehmen.
Ich hätte eindeutig Samsung gekauft damals.
Die schwenkbare Digitalkamera bei dem Samsung-Gerät hingegen kann ich so schwenken, dass ich auch Video-Telefonien öffnen kann. Dafür hat das Nokia viel Speicher, kann eine halbe Stunde MP3-Musik mit abspielen.
Doch so viel, krass. Wobei der Witz ist, gerade Apple verkauft ja heutzutage Speicherplatz für ein Heidengeld auf ihren Handys. Wenn du da guckst, was der Aufpreis ist, oder auch bei iPads, wenn du da guckst Aufpreis 16, 32, 64, sonst was, der Aufpreis ist absolut lächerlich.
Guckt euch das mal an, also das ist überhaupt gar nicht gerechtfertigt.
Nehmen wir eben mal ein normales iPad. Kann man die nicht mal customisieren?
Muss ich ja vielleicht kaufen jetzt mal? Ah, so, ok. Guckt euch das mal an.
Was? Ich mein, 64G reicht eigentlich, ja. Aber es kostet einfach 170 Euro mehr für, naja, das Vierfache an Speicher.
Das ist unglaublich viel Geld. Ich mein, man darf nicht vergessen, du kriegst zwei Terabyte SSDs heute schon für unter 200 Euro.
Das ist richtig teuer. Und die machen damit so viel Kohle, also das ist wirklich unnormal, was der Speicheraufpreis kostet.
Das haben sie damals auch schon gemacht. Und damals war es halt so, dass du Speicher hattest für 30 Minuten MP3. Das war schon Pog.
Oh Gott, wenn ich sowas schon sehe.
Heute, heute ist es so, heute musst du nichts downloaden, heute streamst du das on the fly.
Ok, gut, man kann sagen, ja natürlich ist Streaming auch downloaden, weil irgendwie müssen die Daten ja zu dir geschickt werden, runtergeladen werden und dann abgeladen werden.
Also ja, Streaming ist im Endeffekt auch downloaden, aber da wurde ja die Sache quasi downloaden und erst wenn der Download fertig war, abgespielt.
Damals hat man noch gescheite Musik gehört.
Fuck, Toss, Toss, Toss.
Ich sag nichts, Toss.
Ok, die Qualität ist so schlecht, damit keiner irgendwas raus erkennt.
Braucht kein Mensch. Niemand.
Siehste, das war das, was ich damals auch schon nicht verstanden hab.
Die haben alle gedacht, wir müssen jetzt krass auf Multimedia machen, weil wir haben jetzt die Bandbreite dafür.
Aber keiner braucht ein Musikvideo auf dem Handy. Du hast das Handy zugeklappt und hast die Musik gehört.
Du wolltest nicht das Video dir angucken.
Die haben, und das hab ich mir damals schon gedacht, die haben zu viel auf Multimedia-Gramm gesetzt, anstatt die Vorteile eben in bessere Usability und bessere Handhabung umzusetzen.
Und Videos braucht kein Mensch.
War ziemlich gut, also man fühlte sich wirklich wie in einer Disco.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Der Ton war ein bisschen dumpfer und man muss natürlich nur jetzt wissen, was will man haben.
Der Ton war dumpfer, weil die Bandbreite fürs Video mit drauf gekommen ist.
Wenn man sich Musik wirklich gut anhört, dann ist es so wie ein Walkman, man sieht lieber das Telekom-Handy.
Oder wenn man sich irgendwie Bilder anschaut.
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage, da müsste ich mir eine Weile drüber Gedanken machen.
Also da muss ich ein bisschen ausholen.
Was hat aus deiner Sicht die heutige Jugend von damals verpasst, beziehungsweise würdest du sagen, was toll war?
Das geht beidseitig, muss man sagen.
Also ich glaube, dass man auch quasi dadurch, dass man heute nicht mehr jung ist, auch Sachen verpasst, die cool wären, wenn man sie mitgekriegt hätte.
So, also eine Sache, die mir so spontan einfällt jetzt ist, weil ich ja eben gesagt habe, drei Konzerte diesen Sommer.
Eine coole Sache, muss ich wirklich sagen, die für mich nicer waren, war die Zeiten, wo die Leute auf Konzerten gestanden haben
und sich das angeschaut haben und nicht durch ihr Handy-Display sich das Konzert angeguckt haben.
Oder, ich meine, es gab Zeiten, da haben die Leute bei der passenden Musik noch Feuerzeug rausgeholt und rumgeschwenkt.
Das war vielleicht nicht so geil, weil das ist mit dem Handy vielleicht doch ein bisschen safer, anstatt sich den Finger zu verbrennen.
Aber allein schon, dass die Leute auf dem Konzert da gestanden haben und nicht alle ihr Handy bzw. ihr Smartphone in den Händen hatten, das fand ich war eine coole Geschichte.
Und ansonsten gibt es bestimmt jede Menge Sachen, die coole waren, dabei gewesen zu sein.
Da müsste ich mir jetzt aber erstmal Gedanken machen, da könnte ich jetzt so aus dem Kopf kein wirkliches Best-Of machen.
Die Leute haben definitiv viele gute Spiele verpasst, also wegweisende Spiele, die quasi die Gaming-Landschaft zudem gemacht haben, wie sie heute ist.
Wo man gar nicht das vielleicht zu schätzen weiß heutzutage.
Ich muss halt sagen, bei mir war es so, ich habe quasi mehrere Zeitalter, könnte man sagen, durch. Als ich jung war, ich bin 1984 geboren.
Das heißt, bis so, also sagen wir mal, die ersten zehn Jahre meines Lebens ungefähr, hatte man mit Computer und Sachen gar nichts am Hut.
Also das höchste der Gefühle war, dass da mal irgendwie einer so einen ollen Rechner mit Schwaddeldisketten daheim hatte.
Das heißt, ich hatte tatsächlich so die richtige Oldschool-Jugend die ersten zehn Jahre, nämlich, dass man rausgegangen ist und da Dinger gemacht hat.
So, danach habe ich mitbekommen, wie immer mehr Rechner, Computer und Technologie in den Haushalten sich etabliert hat.
Und ich war ja quasi live dabei, wo die Leute angefangen haben mit Rechnern daheim und wo wir dann auch angefangen haben mit BNC-Kabel und Oldschool-Netzwerkarten.
Wenn das Zeug noch jemand kennt. Wo wir dann angefangen haben mit diesen Netzwerkarten mit T-Stück und BNC-Kabel 10Base2 uns zusammenzustöpseln und dort dann irgendwelche Sachen zu sharen.
Also so Treffen bestanden immer aus. Damals hat man seinen Rechner auch nicht so einfach mal unter den Arm gepackt. Da hatte man damals einen Big Tower, den man eigentlich gar nicht gebraucht hat.
Aber wer den größeren Tower hat, war irgendwie besser. Dann hat man solche Netzwerkarten gehabt, hat sich zusammengestöpselt mit einem T-Stück.
Also man hat, by the way, nicht etwa dieses Kabel da draufgesteckt, sondern man hat ein T-Stück genommen und an das T-Stück das Kabel gesteckt und am Ende musste ein Terminator drauf, dass das funktioniert.
So und das war nur lokales Netzwerk von Internet, hat da noch keiner daheim so gesprochen. Die Hälfte dieser Treffen bestand aus Filesharing.
Die Leute hatten halt irgendwelche Games, irgendwelche Sachen, die hat man sich über komische Windows-Shares gezogen und man hat Sachen gespielt.
Und man hat quasi bei jedem Treffen Windows neu installiert. Also ich kann mich gar nicht mehr dran erinnern, wie oft ich Windows 95 und Windows 98 im Endeffekt neu installiert habe.
Man hat quasi bei jedem Treffen, wo man sich per Netzwerk zusammengestöpselt hat, hat irgendwas nicht funktioniert und die Standard Antwort darauf, ja wir installieren Windows neu.
Und das heißt, so die ersten zwei, drei Stunden waren quasi alle damit beschäftigt, Windows neu zu installieren.
Und danach ging es meistens. Und du musstest in Windows so komische Settings machen. Du hast NetBIOS musstest du aktivieren. NetBUI musstest du aktivieren, falls diesen Crap noch jemand kennt.
Ja IPs, damals dachte man 192.168.0.1.255.255.255.0 ist die einzig mögliche IP-Adresse. Also das einzige Netz, man wusste gar nicht, dass es da was anderes gibt.
IPX für manche Spiele noch genau. Was war das? SPX, IPX, das war auch so ein Doppelname. Musste man alles aktivieren, dass es funktioniert. Ja und man hat dann entweder File geshared oder Spiele geshared.
Also gehört dazu Falsche. Oder halt irgendwelche Sachen gespielt, ja. Wir haben dann beispielsweise ganz viel Half-Life Multiplayer gespielt, normalen Multiplayer, CS und das war halt auch teilweise über null Mode im Kabel noch. Das war halt richtig geil für die damalige Zeit normales Half-Life Multiplayer zu spielen.
Ja und auch gegen Bots gespielt und sonst was. Das war der Anfang von Multiplayer-Spielen in dem Sinn. So und nach dieser Phase ging es dann langsam so in das, was die Leute heute auch kennen.
Nur dass es für viele damals absolutes Hexenwerk war. Nämlich Internet. Ganz am Anfang noch mit 56k Modem. Ich hatte damals ein richtig krasses Highend Modem.
Ein Elsa Microlink Office hatte ich damals. Das ist ein Modem. Was? Das da war das. Das ist ein 56k Modem. Das hat lange bei mir überlebt dieses Ding. Noch längst als 56k aus der Mode war.
Das ist ein Modem. Das hat eingebaut Fax und Anrufbeantworter. Also du hattest in diesem Modem. Das war wirklich seiner Zeit voraus damals. Du hattest quasi ein 56k Modem plus die Möglichkeit Faxe da drüber zu schicken.
Plus 4MB. Du hattest 4MB glaube ich war das. Muss ich mal kurz gucken.
Internal Flash. Wie lange hatte das? Weiß man nicht mehr. Ich glaube das hatte 4MB Flash intern. Dieses Modem. Und da konntest du Faxe und Anrufe drauf speichern.
Und das war gar nicht mal so schlecht für die damalige Zeit. Und das geile war halt dass du so ein Kombi Gerät hast. Und ich hab das lange Zeit noch nach 56k Modem verwendet.
Weil damals war es halt so Faxe konntest du nur empfangen wenn du ein Fax Gerät hattest. Das Fax Gerät musste ja präsent sein wenn dir einer ein Fax geschickt hat.
Und Anrufbeantworter ging halt auch nur wenn was dran gegangen ist. Und die Qualität war sicherlich nicht die geilste. Gerade bei den Audio Aufnahmen. Aber man hat es verstanden.
Ich mein generell Telefon Übertragung ist eh krass komprimiert von Haus aus. Also nicht komprimiert in Form von irgendwie mp3 oder so. Sondern es wird von der gesamten Frequenz quasi 90% weggelassen.
Deswegen hören sich die Leute übers Telefon auch so komplett anders an. Also über das ältere Telefon so komplett anders an als in echt. So und bin ich jetzt da drauf gekommen. Genau. Also das war so das erste was ich hatte für Internet Einwahl.
Und damit ist man dann ins Internet und dann hat man sich. Ich weiß noch ich hab nach der Schule zusammen mit einem Freund damals aus der Schule haben wir uns bei mir getroffen.
Und wir sind immer danach hin. Und dann haben wir damals angefangen die Internet Verbindung zu scheren. Über 56K Modern. Dann waren wir mit zwei Leuten quasi zusammen im Internet mit 56K Modern.
Und ihr werdet es nicht glauben. Aber das hat funktioniert. Das hat nicht gut funktioniert im Vergleich zu heute. Aber es hat funktioniert. Wir haben das damals gemacht mit irgendeinem komischen Troxy und mit weiss gar nicht.
Aber das habe ich damals verwendet. Über 56K Modern scheren. Ja dieses Teil alter. WinRootLite. Damals habe ich damals meine 56K Modern Geschichten geschert mit noch einem Kumpel aus der Schule.
Ja so danach danach ISDN. Wobei ISDN hatte ich tatsächlich nicht lange als Internet Quelle sondern irgendwann und ich war ich will es jetzt nicht übertreiben und ich weiß es auch nicht bestätigt dass es so ist.
Aber ich behaupte jetzt einfach mal ich war unter den ersten zehn Leuten die hier bei mir im Ort einen DSL Anschluss bekommen haben.
Die Telekom hat gesagt es gibt DSL und es war damals eine absolute Oddysee. Das weiß ich noch. Die Telekom hat gesagt es gibt DSL und mein Vater damals hat gesagt jawoll das holen wir.
Und hat es bei der Telekom abgeschlossen sobald das möglich war. Und die Telekom hat es mit dem Ausbau nicht hinbekommen. Das war es im Prinzip der gleiche Scheiß wie heute.
Also wir hätten es bekommen sollen. Ich sage jetzt einfach mal 1998 im Januar und es hat sich nichts getan. Es hat sich nichts getan.
Mein Vater hat täglich dort angerufen und hat bei den Stress gemacht. Der hatte sogar irgendwann den Durchwahl die direkte Durchwahl zum hessischen Telekom Chef.
Weil er denen so sehr auf den Sack gegangen ist und hat den täglich angerufen dass der Ausbau nicht vorwärts geht.
Und der ist dann immer aus allen Wolken gefallen so nach dem Motto wie immer noch nicht.
Zu geil. Und irgendwann haben sie es dann geschafft. Die Hardware hatte ich schon lange angeschlossen.
Und irgendwann hatten sie es dann geschafft und ich weiß es heute noch ohne Scheiß Telekom DSL Modem. Das muss ich jetzt war das fette.
Das war das fette Old School Telekom Modem.
Moment. Keines davon.
Das war das fette. Das war das Old School. Dieses dicke. Nicht das. Ähnlich. Ähnlich wie das. Das ist das zweite was es gegeben hat.
Das ganz dicke Old School Telekom DSL Modem. Das allererste. Weiß nicht ob es davon überhaupt noch ein Bild gibt.
Das hier war das. Das hier.
Hier. Pre-UR2 DSL Modem. Das hier war das.
Das war ein ganz fetter Metallkasten noch. Und er hatte an der Seite Lampen.
Und ich kann mich noch heute so erinnern als wäre es gestern gewesen. Guckt mal was das für ein fettes Ding war. Guckt euch das mal an.
30 Zentimeter Box. Und es war auch schwer.
So. Und das hatte hier neben.
Das hatte hier neben ein Sync. Ein Sync LED.
So. Und ich kann mich noch dran erinnern Leute. Ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Ich kann mich heute noch erinnern als das erste mal der Sync von Rot auf geplinkt Grün und dann auf Grün gegangen ist.
Ich habe da neben gestanden. Ich bin nämlich jeden Tag aus der Schule gekommen. Bin an das DSL Modem gegangen.
Und habe drauf geguckt ob der Sync schon da ist. Weil es die Telekom einfach nicht hinbekommen hat.
Und an dem einen Tag hieß es doch doch wir haben das jetzt geschaltet.
Dann muss die Strom rausziehen und Strom wieder reinstecken und es hat gesyncht.
Normalerweise war das immer so. Das ist rot gegangen. Hat geplinkt. Hat geplinkt. Hat geplinkt und ist dann rot geblieben.
Und ich weiß noch. Ich habe es eingeschaltet. Es war rot. Es hat geplinkt. Es hat rot geplinkt.
Und irgendwann hat es Grün geplinkt und dann ist es auf Grün stehen geblieben.
Leute. Das war eines der krassesten Gefühle die ich je hatte wenn es um Technik geht.
Da kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern. Der Sync des DSL Modems von Rot gesynkt auf Grün.
Da war richtig PogChamp an. Also ich habe so davor gesessen jeden Tag und da war richtig PogChamp angesagt.
Diese Story muss auf YouTube. Hallo YouTube in den Chat Leute. Vielleicht lade ich das ja auch 1 zu 1 so hoch.
Also das war wirklich eines der krassesten Gefühle die ich technikbasiert je hatte.
Und das Geile war. Das Geile war. Also zu dieser damaligen Zeit es hatte niemand.
Ich kannte zu der Zeit niemand der DSL hatte. Und das Geile war als wir dann das erste Mal zusammen.
Also mit meinem besten Freund aus der Schule. Als wir das erste Mal zusammen bei mir mit Netzwerk gesessen haben.
Und sind ins Internet zusammen. Und konnten dort dann. Ich glaube war sogar schon Counter Strike.
Ja war Counter Strike. Konnten dort dann tatsächlich richtig gut Multiplayer Games spielen.
Und du hattest natürlich Probleme gehabt. Damals noch auch mit DSL. Der Ping war nicht sonderlich gut.
Weil kein Fastpass Interleaving Geschiss. Wo ich bis heute nicht so genau weiß warum man das überhaupt jemals gemacht hat.
Und damals wurde Fastpass auch nicht auf Nachfrage aktiviert.
Da musstest du quasi auch nochmal Hardcore die Telekom nerven bis es dann passiert ist.
Aber an diese ohne Scheiß sollte ich kann mich noch an diese LED Anordnung erinnern.
Weil es war bei mir damals so. In meinem Kinderzimmer war links neben der Tür.
Links neben der Tür hing die ganze Technik. Und ich konnte direkt beim um die Ecke gucken der Tür auf die Sync LEDs gucken.
Und ich hab quasi neben dem Modem geschlafen damals. Jetzt ohne Spaß. Mein Bett war quasi direkt daneben.
Ich hab immer auf mein DSL Sync geguckt. Der DSL Sync. Diese LED war damals quasi eines der wichtigsten Signale in meinem Leben.
Ich hab immer darauf geachtet dass diese LED aufgrün ist. Jetzt kann ich das nicht übertrieben Leute. Das war echt so.
Ich hab daneben geschlafen. Mein Bett war direkt daneben. Ich hab nachts auf die Sync LED des DSL Modems geschaut.
Und immer wenn es mal kurz rot war, weil die Sync konnte immer mal passieren, hab ich Panik bekommen gedacht.
Fuck. Hoffentlich geht das morgen wieder. Ja. Echt Wahnsinn. Und das war dieses DSL Modem. Also es war quasi ein.
Wir haben es ja hier gelernt. Wo war das DSL Modem?
Ups. Das war. Geh weg. Das war ein Pre-U32. UR2. DSL. ADSL Modem. Alles klar.
So und dann hat es hier unten noch Anschlüsse. Was war das nochmal? Mal kurz gucken was da unten noch alles dran war.
Also hier war Stromanschluss. Das war Hardcoded. Muss überlegen. Du hast dir das DSL Modem doch direkt in die Steckdose gesteckt.
Nicht irgendwie ein 12 Volt Netzteil oder so. Nein, nein. Direkt in einem Gerät mit Spannungswandler. Was ja kein Ding ist. Das Ding war fett genug.
Ich hab das übrigens noch irgendwo. Irgendwo hab ich es noch. Das werd ich wahrscheinlich auch nie wegschmeißen. Irgendwo hab ich es noch.
Das DSL Modem von damals. So. Hier weiß ich nicht wozu man das verwendet hat. Da musste nichts angeschlossen werden.
Hier kam das Kabel von aus der Wand rein. Oder vom Splitter. Das Kabel vom Splitter kam hier rein.
Und hier kam die Netzwerkkarte dran. 10BaseT Netzwerkkarte. Damals hat es natürlich komplett ausgereicht.
10 MBit. Weil wie gesagt 286K Sync. Äh 268K Sync. 10 MBit. Komplett ausgereicht.
Und ich hatte damals eine Netzwerkkarte. Das weiß ich noch. Ich hatte damals ja so eine komische Netzwerkkarte hier.
Noch mit BNC Stecker. Und das war. Die sah auch ähnlich aus wie die hier. Und das war aus heutiger Sicht glaube ich die beschissenste Netzwerkkarte die ich je hatte.
Die Treiber von dem Ding waren so der. Also Windows natürlich. Oder Windows 95 Treiber waren so dermaßen schlecht.
Also sowas hab ich nie wieder erlebt. Ich mein seitdem. Also die letzten 20 Jahre nimmt man das ja eigentlich komplett als gegeben an.
Dass man eine Netzwerkkarte im Rechner hat. Dort steckt man ein Kabel rein. Und dann züngt sich das. Und dann geht das einfach auch.
Das war nicht so. Also entweder war die Hardware beschissen. Oder die Treiber beschissen. Das weiß ich noch.
Das Ding hatte so oft Disconnects. Und gerade über BNC. Weil mein internes Netzwerk hier damals in der Wohnung und so. Das war ja noch BNC.
Das ging teilweise einfach nicht. Das war so mies. Und ich hab damals auch öfters Treiber getunt anhand. Wobei ich glaube ich schon eine PCI Karte keine ISA Karte hatte.
Ich hab damals irgendwelche Treiber Settings in Windows getunt und haste nicht gesehen. Und die Netzwerkkarte war so beschissen.
Und ich war halt damals ein richtiger Kacknoob. Ich wollte diese Netzwerkkarte ursprünglich gar nicht kaufen.
Aber. Und jetzt kommt der Chebathe des Jahrhunderts für mich. Ich bin damals in so ein komisches PC Geschäft gegangen.
So richtig gab damals noch jede Menge kleine Klitschen die so PC Teile verkauft haben.
PC Spezialist. Phobis. Falls du einer Phobis kennt. Größter Kackladen aller Zeiten.
Wie die mich mal Chebathe mit einer Druckerpatrone. Ist eine andere Story.
Und ich bin in so einen kleinen Klitschenladen gegangen und hab mir eine Netzwerkkarte gekauft.
Und ich wollte mir damals eigentlich eine andere kaufen. Zwar auch mit dem Realtek Chip aber irgendwas anderes.
So und ich hab mich damals beschwätzen lassen von diesem Typ. Weil. Jetzt passt mal auf.
Die. Wie soll ich sagen. Die offensichtliche Chebathe kannst du die Leute nicht mit offensichtlicherem Bullshit.
Aber ich hab's damals geglaubt. Der hat gesagt. Hier Jungs. Diese Netzwerkkarte ist die beste Netzwerkkarte die wir haben.
Also nicht explizit die hier. Das ist sinnbildlich so eingeplant. Also bildlich jetzt mal eingeplant.
Die Netzwerkkarte ist die beste die wir haben. Die ist mit Technologie aus der Raumfahrt.
Das hat er mir damals gesagt. Und ich war komplett beeindruckt. Und ich hab gedacht. Boah. Netzwerkkarten aus der Raumfahrt.
Netzwerkkarten aus der Raumfahrt. Damals war ich noch richtiger Zoomer Alter. Vom Alter her.
Netzwerkkarten aus der Raumfahrt. Alter ist das geil. Das will ich auch haben.
Da hab ich mir Netzwerkkarte aus der Raumfahrt gekauft. Und hab festgestellt die Netzwerkkarte ist mit Abstand die beschissenste Netzwerkkarte die ich je hatte.
Zumindest an der war dann das DSL Modell dran. Und äh über RJ45 Sachen ging es auch halbwegs gescheit.
So. Ja. Das war also die Sachen damals beim ersten DSL. Also nicht ersten DSL Anschluss. Erster DSL Anschluss.
Das war für mich wirklich ein riesen Highlight. An Sachen wie WLAN hat damals noch keiner gedacht.
Das war alles Kabel. Und es ist heute immer noch so Kabelbeste. Wo Kabel möglich ist Kabel.
Ja und 10 MBit war damals ein unvorstellbar schnelles Zeug.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen. Das war zu Zeiten. Da war Windows 98 so brandneu. Pleading Edge Technologie.
Windows 98. Damals hat man sich. Gucken ob man das sieht.
Äh ja sowas hier in der Richtung. Damals hat man sich dann mit Sachen rumgeschlagen.
Wie zum Beispiel diesen komischen MSDN Setup mit Internet Explorer 4 oder was es damals gewesen ist.
Und man hat sich natürlich damit rumgeschlagen dass Windows 98 bei jedem Kram den Geist drauf gegeben hat.
Also ganz ehrlich die Netzwerk Umgebung. Die kenne ich auswendig noch von Windows 98.
Da musstest du so viele Sachen einstellen. Wie gesagt IPX für Spiele. NetBIOS, NetBOE.
Im dritten Untermenu Hähnchen hin machen. Dass es funktioniert. Im Netzwerk 3 irgendwelche Hähnchen hin machen.
Aber Leute ich sag euch es war eine komplett neue Welt wenn man DSL hatte.
Der Unterschied zu ASDN bzw. 56K Modem und DSL das ist ohne Scheiß.
Man kann sich das heute glaube ich in der Form gar nicht vorstellen. Das war eine komplett neue Welt.
Und damals gab es Amazon richtig. Amazon hat damals hauptsächlich Bücher verkauft.
Und hat sich auch in Deutschland Amazon ausgesprochen und nicht Amazon in ihrer eigenen Werbung.
Also das war eine komplett neue Welt mit DSL.
Ja so genug vom Griech erzählt. Machen wir jetzt weiter.
Kurz Chat gucken ob es da noch was gibt.
Ja siehst du mal mit der Frage hast du mich da drauf gebracht.
Ja gute Idee.
Ich habe Peak Entwicklung mitbekommen was Gaming angeht. Ich habe quasi die Entstehung der ganzen Computer und Technologie in den eigenen Verwenden mitbekommen.
Ich habe quasi die Entstehung des Internets mitbekommen. Und ich hatte noch 10 Jahre normale Jugend wie man sich das vorher vorstellt.
Icq war damals. Xfire habe ich nie verwendet. Kennt noch jemand Hamachi. Hamachi VPN. Kennt ich diesen Krempel noch jemand.
Das war VPN bevor man wusste dass es VPN hieß. Hamachi und Team Speak natürlich Team speed und wisst ihr.
Leute ich kann mich nur dran erinnern, wisst ihr was die Leute teilweise verwendet haben vor und zu 10 teamspeak zeiten?
Kennt noch jemand Roger Wilco oder wie das?
Ah ne ne, Wil, Wilco wie hieß der Kram?
So? Nein, Roger.
Software?
Das Ding! Kennt diesen Müll noch jemand?
Das war so ein Rotz!
Das war auch so eine Voice Chat Software.
Und danach Teamspeak, Teamspeak war damals wirklich die absolute Krone der Softwareentwicklung für uns.
Und ICQ natürlich, ICQ. Und wisst ihr was das beste an ICQ war?
ICQ Sumo Volleyball.
ICQ Sumo Volleyball, beste.
Das waren quasi Multiplayer Minigames bevor es Mobile Games gab.
Sumo Volleyball, aller, aller beste Game überhaupt.
Moment, es gibt Sumo Volleyball auf GitHub?
Ne, ist irgendwas anderes.
Sumo Volleyball eSport, es gab damals tatsächlich Sumo Volleyball Turniere, kein Spaß jetzt.
Wobbly, ja Blobby Volley gab es auch, aber Sumo Volleyball war nicer.
Über ICQ Multiplayer.
Ja was mit ICQ los ist verstehe ich auch nicht, das gehören jetzt ja irgendwelchen Russen ICQ.
Aber das war schon irgendwie für die Zeit damals ziemlich cool.
Zumal ICQ hatte nicht die Möglichkeit Leuten Nachrichten zuzustellen, wenn sie offline waren.
Das ging nicht, du konntest Nachrichten schicken, wenn die Leute offline waren,
aber diese Nachrichten wurden erst zugestellt, wenn sie online gekommen sind.
Und damit konntest du damals auch feststellen, wenn jemand anonym online gekommen ist,
weil du gesehen hast ob deine Nachricht zugestellt wurde.
Ja die Nummer hat sich ins Hirn gebrannt, die kriege ich heute wahrscheinlich noch zum Teil zusammen.
Ja ICQ.
So.
Null Modere im Kabel, ja falls das einer nicht kennt.
Null Modere im Kabel, Parallelport, weil noch besser.
Das war ein Parallelport Multi, Multi, nein nein nein, das ist Serial.
Hier Parallel.
Wo ist das, wo ist das Parallel, hier, ne da.
Null Modere im Kabel, Parallelport.
Die beste.
100, 160k oder irgendwie sowas, was da drüber ging.
Immerhin noch schneller als Modern.
Oder war es sogar 300? War es sogar 320k oder irgendwie sowas?
Moment.
Mal kurz schauen, was da maximal drüber ging.
115k?
Wie ist das mit Parallel?
Es war auf jeden Fall schneller als Modern.
Und zu ISDN Zeiten fällt mir auch noch kurz eine Sache ein, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Bei ISDN musstest du ja doppelt bezahlen.
Du musstest bei ISDN oder bei Modern auch, du musstest ja doppelt bezahlen.
Du musstest ja bezahlen, quasi Einwahl und Telefonkosten.
Und du hast da mal sowas wie MSN Call by Call gemacht zum Beispiel.
Da gab es dann irgendein, guck mal hier.
MSN startet zweites Internet bei Call angeboten.
Du hast da sowas wie MSN Call by Call gemacht.
Das heißt du hast deinen Provider bezahlt und die Telefonkosten bezahlt.
Und am Wochenende hast du bei der Telekom die Telefongebühren umsonst bekommen.
Also umsonst, du musstest keine Telefongebühren bezahlen, so viel.
Und das lief daraus raus, dass man damals am Wochenende die Ultra-Download-Aktion gestartet.
Also man hat da gesaugt, was das Zeug hält, Napster aufgemacht und erstmal das halbe Internet runtergeladen.
ISDN mit Kanalbündelung.
Und ich weiß noch, wie fasziniert ich damals war, Napster, dass man mit Kanalbündelungen schnell genug war.
Ich meine, ISDN-Kanalbündelung hast du theoretisch 128K.
Also maximale Übertragung, glaube ich.
Oder 256? Nee, 128. Nee, 128. Garantiert nicht. 128.
So und du konntest damals, wenn du einen guten Host in Napster erwischt hast,
konntest du Musik runterladen und während sie runtergeladen wird, schon anfangen abzuspielen.
Das war das erste Mal, dass ich in meinem Leben Musik gestreamt hab, quasi.
Ich hab im Napster gesagt, Download, ich weiß, ich hab irgendwas von Metallica damals runtergeladen vor 20 Jahren.
Und was ich natürlich nie machen würde, jetzt heutzutage, keinem empfehlen.
Ihr wisst ja, kein Toss.
Aber damals vor 20 Jahren hab ich irgendwie mal Metallica runtergeladen bei Napster.
Ausgerechnet Metallica ist eigentlich doppelt Kekwe, weil das die ersten waren, die dann auch richtig gegen Napster vorgegangen sind.
Hab ich runtergeladen vor 20 Jahren.
Und ich konnte es abspielen während dem Download.
Das war wirklich mindblown zur damaligen Zeit.
Was, wie das geht? Man kann Sachen abspielen, bevor sie fertig runtergeladen sind.
Napster war schon prog damals. Es gab ja noch so viel Zeug damals.
Napster hattest du damals, dann hattest du Audio Galaxy hieß das, glaube ich, noch.
Dann hattest du E-Dunkey, E-Mule, LimeWire, Kazaar.
Und Good News Net ist ja immer noch der Old-Oldtime-Klassiker.
Alles. Dieses ganze Ding damals.
Irgendwann später torrent? Irgendwann bisschen später torrent.
Beershare! Beershare, Alter!
Ich erinnere mich, Beershare, Alter! Genau!
Kann man das eingeben, ohne dass das Monkartos...
Das war definitiv nicht das Logo von Beershare damals.
Beershare, genau.
Das ganze Craftzeug, Alter.
Ich erinnere mich noch, ja.
Und ich erinnere mich auch noch an die ersten Torrents.
Da wo du noch keine Angst haben musstest, dass du irgendwelche Anwälte am Start hattest instant.
Ich erinnere mich noch an die ersten Zeit von Torrents.
Wo dann immer Download war bis 95% und der letzte Seed hat gefehlt.
Da kam auch nie on. Du hattest so viele Torrent-Downloads, die quasi fast fertig waren und nie fertig geworden sind.
Und die ganzen Torrent-Downloads waren ja alle irgendwelche RAR-Files oder sonst was.
Die konntest du ja auch nicht entpacken, wenn die Hälfte, wenn nur 95% gefehlt hat.
Ja, und als dann Torrent und sowas zunehmend unsicherer wurde, wie gesagt, zwar jetzt mal ehrlich.
Ich habe die letzten 10 Jahre, glaube ich, nichts mehr raubkopiert in dieser Richtung.
Ich habe heute einfach Abos, weil sie erschwinglich sind, was Musik und Videos angeht.
Aber damals sah das anders aus. Damals waren ja beispielsweise viele in der Musikindustrie noch der Meinung,
Leute kauft CDs und die Leute haben gesagt, wir wollen keine CDs kaufen.
Die haben gesagt, doch, ihr müsst aber CDs kaufen.
Ja, und dann sind die Leute ins Internet gegangen, haben sich den Kram runtergeladen.
Ja, und danach kam sowas wie Rapid Share und irgendwann Mega-Upload.
Mega kam dann irgendwann, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Irgendwann später dann, ja. Oh man.
Boomer erzählt vom Griech, ey, heute.
Du hast mal einen Torrent mit 0,5 Kb gezogen, drei Monate. Ja, ja, das war normal fast schon.
Diese Story muss auf YouTube. Vielleicht lasse ich das wirklich zusammenschneiden zu einem YouTube Video.
Ich habe jemand, der das macht, aber ich weiß nicht, irgendwie finde ich so wenig Content interessant für YouTube,
den ich hier mache, weil auf YouTube ist halt was anderes angesagt als hier.
Wann hattest du dir deinen ersten Virus eingefangen?
Das ist tatsächlich schon länger her. Den allerersten Virus, also den ich jemals gesehen habe,
so unbewusst bei meinem Vater in der Firma auf den Rechnern damals, da war was,
kam ich ganz, ganz entfernt im Hinterkopf, aber der erste richtige Virus war auf einem Amiga mit Disketten.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern, irgendwelche Sachen, die die Disketten überschrieben haben und so.
So, und der erste richtige Virus, Internet und vom Rechner?
Ich weiß nicht, was der erste war, ehrlich. Doch, doch, doch, ich weiß es, ich weiß es, ich glaube zumindest, dass es der erste war.
Der erste Virus, den sich ein Freund von mir aus der Schule und ich eingefangen haben, war auf einer CD,
auf einer Sicherheitskopie von, falls dieses Game noch jemand kennt, kennt das Game noch jemand?
Ein richtig nicees Strategie-Game, Jacked Alliance 2, Söldner Stels-Game und da hatten wir eine Sicherheitskopie auf CD
und auf dieser CD war ein Virus drauf, der zunehmend alle anderen Dateien auf der Platte infiziert hat.
Das war so der erste Virus, den ich wirklich mal mitbekommen habe bei mir.
Das war damals, ich weiß noch, das war ja Pre-Internet, da konnte ja nicht wirklich viel passieren.
Wobei, wann war da Release? Wann war Release Date? Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Pre-Internet noch war.
Ja, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, das war nicht, das war schon, da hatten wir schon Internet.
Aber damals hat man sich keine Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Das war so, man musste den Virenscanner ausmachen, damit man das Spiel spielen konnte.
Weil, wenn der Virenscanner den Virus entfernt hat, dann hat er die Spieldateien kaputt gemacht.
Das heißt, man hat quasi, das ist doch bescheuert aus heutiger Zeit eigentlich.
Das heißt, man hat den Virenscanner ausgeschaltet, damit man die Spiele spielen konnte
und hat dann quasi so lange gewartet, bis die Festplatte fast komplett voll infiziert war
und dann hat man sich sein Save-File runterkopiert und entweder den Virenscanner laufen lassen oder Windows neu installiert.
Man wollte es ja spielen als Scheiß auf den Virus in dem Game, ja?
Wenn Drillo stimmt, dann habe ich auch komplett, das gab es ja auch noch, ja.
Oh man. Sieht aus wie DVI, nee, DVI ist kleiner und hat mehr Reihen.
Parallelport war richtig fett.
Da hatte ich Glück, sowas hatte ich nie. Sowas, sowas hatte ich nie.
Wie bin ich jetzt da eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Wegen dieser komischen Liste, die ich so verpackt habe, dass ich mir so ein bisschen was abgelassen habe,
dass ich mir so so ein bisschen was abgelassen habe, dass ich mir so ein bisschen was abgelassen habe,
Wie bin ich jetzt da eigentlich drauf gekommen?
Wegen dieser komischen UMTS Geschichte bin ich hier drauf gekommen.
Alter, jetzt hab ich drei Minuten Video geguckt, eine halbe Stunde geschwätzt.
Okay, wir gucken mal, ist das immer fertig.
Guck mal, das ist ne Ansicht, die hat man heute immer noch mobile in Deutschland öfters.
Und nicht nur mobile.
Pass mal auf.
Das da, buffering.
Das kommt heute immer noch so oft vor, das hat man sich 2003 wahrscheinlich nicht vorgestellt,
dass 2022 immer noch so viel gebuffert wird.
Woran das liegt, dass man kaum Viren wie früher baut?
Das liegt zum größten Teil daran, Pufferung.
Ja, das haben wir doch auf Deutsch geschrieben.
Das liegt zum größten Teil daran, weil sich die Viren gewandelt haben.
Also damals war es ja hauptsächlich auf Verbreitung über Disketten und solche Geschichten ausgelegt,
wobei es heute immer noch nicht zu unterschätzen ist, was für eine Vielzahl der Viren tatsächlich über Mail und solche Oldschool Geschichten kommt.
Aber es hat sich heute ein bisschen gewandelt.
Damals waren Viren mehr oder weniger darauf ausgelegt, ja gut, kommt in irgendeiner Art und Weise auf den Rechner,
macht dann dort die Festplatte kaputt, schreibt vielleicht beim Booten was Lustiges hin und fertig.
So, heute ist ein Virus weniger, es gibt keine klassischen Viren mehr wie damals.
Heute hast du eher solche Sachen wie, du hängst dann instant in einem Botnetz drinnen und sowas.
So diese Viren, die, ich mach dein Windows kaputt und schreib dir beim Starten irgendwas hin.
Wozu? Das macht heute keiner mehr.
Heute hängst du im Botnetz oder hast ein Krypto-Trojaner oder sowas drauf.
Es gibt heute einfach komplett andere Viren, dementsprechend bekommt man die Viren wie früher auch gar nicht mehr,
weil die gibt es in dieser Art auch nicht mehr oder nicht mehr neu.
Und die Viren von damals, gut, die erkennt halt jeder Windows Defender.
Und die sind halt auch nicht im Umlauf, die sind ja auch nicht für Verbreitung über Webseiten und so vorgesehen gewesen.
So, aber jetzt.
Das Bildangebot geht soweit, dass Vodafone in Kooperation mit dem Nachrichtensender N24 das Modul...
N24, das ist auch so ein Kack, so ein Crap-Sender, da läuft den ganzen Tag nur irgendwie Reportagen, was weiß ich,
Hitlers größter Flugzeugträger und sowas, der übrigens gar keinen hatte.
Aber das ist im Prinzip nur solche Reportagen laufen auf N24, den ganzen Tag.
... zum Minifernseher macht.
Dass Nokia eher geeignet ist, um MP3s und ähnliches abzuspielen, gibt es von der Telekom im Moment...
Was ist der Unterchat, das müssen wir mal kurz beantworten.
Auch wenn ich mir bei den Definitionen aus dem Kopf jetzt nicht so hundertprozentig sicher bin,
Ransomware ist eine spezielle Art von Malware.
Malware ist ja im Prinzip alles was Schädliches.
Und Ransomware ist eine Unterkategorie von Malware, die versucht, dein Rechner zu verschlüsseln und Lösegeld von dir zu erpressen.
Die sagen dann, hey, wir haben deinen Rechner verschlüsselt, wenn du deine Daten wieder haben willst,
dann musst du uns Bitcoin überweisen oder sowas.
Was erstaunlich viele wohl machen, weil sonst wird es sich nicht lohnen.
... Hand zum Minifernseher macht.
Da das Nokia sehr geeignet ist, um MP3s und ähnliches abzuspielen...
Alter, dieses Handy, was hat sich der Nokia dabei gedacht?
Das sieht aus wie ein Blutdruckmessgerät.
Oder vielleicht ein Wecker, aber das sieht doch nicht aus wie ein Handy.
Was zum Teufel soll das sein?
... gibt es von der Telekom im Moment ein eher größeres Angebot an Klingeltönen...
Oder Tamagotchi, genau.
Oh, da habe ich richtig Ärger gekriegt bei einem Tamagotchi früher.
Ein Kumpel aus der Schule, die kleine Schwester hatte, ein Tamagotchi,
und ich habe das dann auf dem Schrank versteckt und dann ist das Viech abgekratzt.
Boah, die Mutter hat mich zur Sau gemacht von der.
Das weiß ich heute noch. Die hat mich richtig zur Sau gemacht.
Nokia ist alter, die hat mich richtig zur Sau gemacht.
Ich mein, hey, macht man ja auch nicht, ja? Macht man ja auch nicht.
Oh, die hat geheult. Die war fertig, als wäre irgendein Haustier gestorben.
Die war richtig durch.
Das hast du richtig gemeint von mir. Ja, war es auch.
Witzig ist, dass es Handys in dieser Bauart heute noch gibt.
... versucht Vodafone im Moment eher, diese Streaming-Anwendung weiterzureichen.
Das heißt, ich kann mir aktuelle Fußballtore live im bewegten Bild anschauen.
Musikclips von Britney Spears oder ähnliches.
Sie muss ich gucken auf dem Handy.
Doch UMTS kann noch mehr, zum Beispiel online gehen.
Der Eintritt in die virtuelle Welt soll mit UMTS-Geräten sechsmal schneller gelingen als...
Gut, mit UMTS war das erste Mal möglich, dass du normales Internet-Zeug auf dem Handy verwendest.
Vorher hattest du Sachen wie WAP. Kennt noch irgendeiner WAP?
Nicht ab, WAP.
Kennt diesen hässlichen Crap noch jemand?
WAP.
Ja.
Und das war schon richtig hyper-advanced, so eine Seite.
Es war eher sowas in dieser Richtung realistisch betrachtet.
WAP-Intervall, das muss ich mal kurz gucken.
YouTube über WAP zu eken.
Ich dachte, der spielt jetzt da auch was ab drüber.
WAP.
WAP war viel zu teuer.
Über dieses Kabel stellen wir jetzt die Verbindung zwischen Handy und Notebook her.
Das ist eine normale USB-Verbindung.
Aber natürlich proprietärer Stecker am Handy.
Das war natürlich eine coole Sache für die damalige Zeit, dass man ein Notebook,
heute hat keiner mehr Notebook dabei, weil du die meisten Sachen hier internettechnisch am Handy direkt magst,
dass man ein Modem haben konnte. Das war wirklich eine richtig gute Anwendung.
Betriebsbereit, man kann also ruck, zuck, los, ruck, zuck.
Der UMTS Datenstrom spielt den Kinotrailer von iRobot direkt aufs Notebook ohne vorheriges Herunterladen.
Theoretisch sind Sendeleistungen von bis zu 384 Kilobit pro Sekunde möglich.
Mit der drahtlosen Funktechnik Bluetooth verbindet Zivadinovic anschließend das Nokia-Handy mit seinem Laptop.
Mit Hilfe eines selbstgeschriebenen Programms, das wie ein Zähler die UMTS Leistung misst,
kann der Computerexperte die Datenstrommengen analysieren.
Das Ergebnis?
Das Samsung, das etwas jüngere Gerät am Markt, hat ungefähr dreimal so hohe Durchsatzraten im Test gehabt wie das Nokia 7600.
Beide, muss man aber sagen, erreichen nicht das theoretische Maximum,
sondern bleiben so das Samsung ungefähr bei 75 Prozent, das Nokia bei vielleicht 30 Prozent.
Die größte Herausforderung stellt allerdings das Internetsurfen in einem bewegten Objekt dar.
Zum Beispiel während einer Autofahrt.
Das ist heute im Zug leider immer noch so.
Also ich habe regelmäßig zweimal an den gleichen Stellen, wenn ich morgens Hanau Frankfurt fahre,
habe ich regelmäßig an den gleichen Stellen zweimal die Bahnfahrt über Verbindungsabbrüche.
Das liegt einfach daran, dass ich es immer noch nicht mit dem Ausbau richtig hinbekomme.
Haben die da Matrix-Hintergrundmusik? Ja, ja, jetzt wo du es sagst, stimmt.
Ja, die haben Matrix-Hintergrundmusik.
Da ist sie futsch.
Ja, eindeutig.
Wir sind jetzt raus aus dem UMTS, müssen die Verbindung neu aufbauen.
Gut, jetzt geht es also wieder weiter.
Die Verbindung ohne größere Umstände wieder aufgebaut, wieder also im Internet drin.
Und jetzt können wir weiter surfen.
Bin ich drin oder was?
Der Experte ist durchaus angetan.
UMTS ist meiner Meinung nach auch auto geeignet, ziemlich gut sogar.
Ich bin überrascht, dass es nur so wenige Aussetzer gibt.
Warum zoomen die so nah an den Typ ran?
Man hätte durchaus mit mehr rechnen können.
Wir sind jetzt 20 Minuten in der Innenstadt unterwegs.
Und es gab halt zwei Verbindungsabbrüche.
Muss man einfach konstatieren, das ist zu Beginn einer Netztechnik,
einer völlig neuen Netztechnik, muss man damit leben, denke ich mal.
Oh.
Mit welchen Kosten der User dabei leben muss, zeigt folgende Übersicht.
Es gibt zwei verschiedene Tarifsysteme.
Zahltet euch fest.
Bei den sogenannten Zeit-Tarifsystemen...
Zahltet euch das Zeug, ist teuer als fuck gewählt.
... wird grundsätzlich im 10-Minuten-Takt abgerechnet.
Je nach Größe der monatlichen Inklusiv-Online-Stundenpakete liegt der Preis zwischen 10 und 70 Euro.
70 Euro, Alter?
Anbieter sind derzeit nur T-Mobile.
Und es ist keine Flatrate gewesen, oder so?
... und Vodafone.
Eine Alternative bietet der sogenannte Volumentarif.
Hier wird, unabhängig von der Verbindungsdauer, nach Datenmenge abgerechnet.
Und zwar in 10 oder 100 Kilobyte-Schritten.
Übrigens, das ist auch so ein Ding gewesen.
Rein zum Geldmachen.
Also, im 10-Minuten-Takt abgerechnet, rein zum Geldmachen.
In Kilobyte, muss ich mal überlegen, Alter.
Das Zeug war damals...
Auch viel zu...
Einfach nur, damit man quasi das immer mit jedem Bit oder mit jeder Sekunde voll macht
und noch mal mehr abgreifen kann.
Als Flatrates gibt es monatliche Byte-Pauschalen.
Die kosten je nach Größe 5 bis 110 Euro.
Neben T-Mobile und Vodafone ist O2 ein weiterer Anbieter.
Moment, Moment, Leute.
Nur weil das heute so ist, das kannst du so nicht sehen.
110 Euro von damals wären wahrscheinlich heute umgerechnet 300 oder so?
Für diesen Service.
Experten empfehlen die Abrechnung nach Volumen.
Da die Verbindungszeiten bei schlechtem Empfang sehr lang werden können.
Dass aber alle diese Tarife zur Markteinführung nicht gerade ein Schnäppchen sind,
rechtfertigen die Betreiber mit ihren milliardenschweren Investitionen.
Tja, da haben sie auch recht.
Da haben sie auch recht.
Das ist immer noch was, wo ich mir bis heute Gedanken drüber mache,
ob es unsere Regierung damals bei der Versteigerung der UMTS-Lizenzen
nicht grundsätzlich für Jahrzehnte für Deutschland,
was Internetausbau angeht, mit verkackt hat.
Man ist ja damals hingegangen und hat gesagt,
hey, wir versteigern die UMTS-Lizenzen und nehmen Millionen ein.
Und dann hat man gesagt, was zur Schuldentilgung oder so.
Das Problem dabei war nur, dass man gesagt hat,
hey, wir nehmen damit Geld ein.
Aber man hat das ja an nichts geknüpft.
Also man hat nicht gesagt, hey, ihr bekommt das.
Ich meine, kann es dir auch schlecht.
Du kannst ja einem schlecht für Millionen was verkaufen
und sagen, ja, aber ihr müsst noch zusätzlich.
Also ich frage mich bis heute, wäre es nicht sinnvoller gewesen,
und ich glaube, da gibt es sogar Untersuchungen zu,
die dazu ähnlichen Schlüssen kommen, wäre es nicht sinnvoller gewesen,
wenn wir sagen, hey, wir geben euch die Lizenzen,
aber im Umkehrschluss verpflichtet ihr euch, auszubauen,
und zwar nachweislich in diesen und diesen Schritten überprüfbar für uns
und im Zweifelsfall auch, wenn ihr euch oft genug nicht dran haltet
und es die Ziele nicht einhaltet, dann mit dementsprechend Sanktionen.
Weil so haben die Anwender das erste Mal massig viel Geld ausgegeben
für UMTS Lizenzen.
Dementsprechend hatten sie natürlich kein Interesse daran, UMTS auszubauen,
außer dort, wo es halt Instant-Fat-Money gibt, was im Prinzip in Frankfurt ist,
aber jetzt vielleicht nicht irgendwie in Dresden auf dem Land.
Und das hat so viel gekostet, dass das wahrscheinlich auch den Ausbau
in anderen Bereichen gehemmt und gebremst hat.
Also ich mache mir da bis heute Gedanken drüber, ob diese einzig nur diese,
und es gab bestimmt noch mehr fragwürdige Entscheidungen, ob nicht,
allein einzig diese Geschichte der UMTS Versteigerungen damals
dazu mitmaßgeblich dazu geführt hat, dass wir heute so weit hinten dran sind,
was Internet- und Technologiesachen sind.
Ich glaube, das war eines der beschissensten Entscheidungen,
die je getroffen wurden technologietechnisch bei uns.
Tja, und da bin ich mal gespannt, also muss ich mal gucken,
da gibt es auch irgendwelche Nachforschungen zu,
da muss man uns mal angucken.
Jetzt scheint er nicht funktioniert zu haben, Basti.
Tja, ähm...
... ein Fahrkuhl von dem Endfachen.
Und in der Tendenz in der 10-jährigen Mobilfunkgeschichte
hat es bei der Preisentwicklung fürs Telefonieren immer nur eine Richtung gegeben,
und das ging nach unten, und das wird sich sicherlich auch fortsetzen.
Ob das reichen wird, um in Sachen drahtlosem Internetzugang
den Konkurrenten WLAN auszustechen, ist zumindest fraglich.
Okay, an der Stelle hat Fokus keine Ahnung gehabt, wovon sie sprechen.
... hat es bei der Preisentwicklung fürs Telefonieren immer nur eine Richtung gegeben,
und das ging nach unten, und das wird sich sicherlich auch fortsetzen.
Ob das reichen wird, um in Sachen drahtlosem Internetzugang den Konkurrenten WLAN auszustechen,
ist zumindest fraglich.
Naja, das hat jetzt einfach mal 15 Jahre gedauert, bis das halbwegs funktioniert hat.
... den Konkurrenten WLAN auszustechen, ist zumindest fraglich.
WLAN.
Immerhin ist eine Wireless-LAN-Verbindung fast dreimal so schnell wie UMTS.
Es ist was komplett anderes, Alter.
WLAN ist ortsgebunden bei den Sender, die es hat...
Ja genau, es hat auch komplett unterschiedliche Anwendungszwecke.
WLAN.
Oder Mobilfunk-Internet.
... in Bars, Airport, Lounge und Bahnhöfen gibt höchstens 50 Meter weit reichen.
Voila, WLAN.
WLAN ist meines Erachtens für die Online-Junkies.
Also wer einen teuren, tragbaren PC hat, ein Notebook,
und da auch im Biergarten oder im Café viele Datenmengen übertragen möchte,
der muss Online-Junkie sein.
Wer nur mal ein bisschen die neuesten Nachrichten sehen will,
vielleicht seine E-Mails checken will, also so ein Gelegenheits-Internet-Nutzer,
für den reicht auch UMTS, dann wird es auch nicht so teuer.
Der Unterschied ist, WLAN ist umsonst.
UMTS kostet brutal viel Geld.
Und ich würde immer WLAN vorziehen, wenn es WLAN gibt.
So jemand wie Christina Peter eben.
Unsere Testerin kann von UMTS gar nicht genug kriegen,
auch wenn sie damit ihre Freundin Nora gewissen Risiken aussetzt.
Nicht gestellt, nicht gestellt, nein.
Alles, alles real, legit.
Würdest du Ubiquiti Access Points haben?
Gleich zu Fritzbox wäre noch empfehlungt.
Jetzt mittlerweile ist es etwas besseres.
Wenn du keine Probleme mit deinen Fritzbox-WLAN hast,
gibt es keinen Grund, da irgendwas zu ändern dran.
Die Ubiquiti-Dinger sind nicht irgendwie super schlecht oder so.
Ich hatte halt so meine Probleme damit.
Und auch von den Features her wollte ich ein bisschen was anderes haben.
Also was ich jetzt von dem Feature-Set, vom Preis her
und von der Oberfläche recht okay fand,
ist diese TP-Link-Omada-Geschichte.
Ich habe aber keine, muss ich sagen.
Nur von dem, was ich gesehen habe bisher,
fand ich das eigentlich keine schlechte Ubiquiti-Alternative.
Die Geräte waren preislich in Ordnung.
Die Oberfläche ist mehr oder weniger ein Unify-Klon.
Wenn einem das gefällt, dann gefällt einem das auch.
Du kriegst halt ein bisschen mehr Features als bei Unify.
Zumindest Features, die mir wichtig sind.
Das Ja des Linux-Destops, ja, ist klar.
Okay, jetzt wissen wir, wie das bei UMTS
in Führung 2003 so gewesen ist.
Alles klar.
Oh Leute, ich kriege Hunger.
Ich kriege Hunger, richtig.
Das gucken wir uns das nächste Mal an.
Was?
Dropping GoPro down a deep mystery pipe.
Alles klar.
Rollen wir mal rein, würde ich sagen.
Dieses Video wurde mir auch heute Morgen empfohlen.
Ich weiß nicht warum.
YouTube dachte, ich möchte sehen,
wie irgendjemand eine GoPro in den Schacht wirft.
An was für einem WLAN?
AVM, ach so, ja.
Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen doof.
Das wirkt so, weil man das braucht, wie gesagt.
Aber das geben ja diese Ubiquiti-Dinger her.
Das eine Feature, was ich unbedingt haben wollte,
ist halt, dass du ein WLAN-Passwort vergeben kannst
und dass du pro Gerät zusätzlich noch WLAN-Passwörter vergeben kannst,
dass du IoT-Geräte bedenkenlos wegschmeißen kannst.
Das Feature wollte ich haben.
Das kann weder die Fritzbox noch Ubiquiti.
Lustigerweise TP-Link kann es.
So, ich will mal gucken, warum YouTube mir das empfohlen hat.
Vielleicht ist das auch irgendwie so ein...
Wie nennt sich das so ein...
Jumpscare-Video.
Und die haben zufälligerweise eine GoPro dabei,
weil sie das mal so gefunden haben und schmeißen die da jetzt rein, oder?
Okay, die müssen die GoPro wieder rauskriegen.
Die müssen die an irgendeine Schnur bitten.
Aha.
Und?
Force-Champ?
Also, ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich stelle es mir relativ unspektakulär vor,
wenn das acht Minuten...
Man sieht dann halt acht Minuten, die GoPro durch so ein Rohr abgeseilt werden.
Ja, und eine Lampe wäre nicht verkehrt.
Ja, da ist sie doch.
Meckalper-Konstruktion, ja.
Ja, das ist auch nicht so gut ausbalanciert von mir.
Ja, das ist auch nicht so gut ausbalanciert vom Gewicht her, das Ding.
Kennst du smarte Steckdosen, die den Stromverbrauch messen?
Ja, kenne ich.
Du musst aber welche finden, die du noch Tasmota-flaschen kannst.
Also, ich habe mir beispielsweise...
Ja, gut, wenn es günstig sei.
Die Shelley-Dinger können das auch.
Aber ich habe mir gekauft als Tasmota-BSD34.
Sind die das?
Nein, das sind die nicht.
...
Ja, die Dinger habe ich mir gekauft.
Die kann man wahrscheinlich nicht mehr flaschen.
Aber das Gute an den Dinger waren, die haben zweimal USB.
Falls das die sind, mit zweimal USB.
Also, ich habe diese Steckdosen, die haben zweimal unten USB.
Normal schaltbares Ding, ein ESP8266.
Und können den Stromverbrauch messen.
Und dann kann man den Kram...
... flaschen.
Wenn man, also damals konnte man den Kram flaschen.
Moment, das sind die ohne WLAN.
Das lege ich nicht durch, ich habe den Kram ohne USB.
Ich habe den Kram mit USB.
Mit USB ist das deutlich besser.
Ja, die da, die da.
USB, diese Teile habe ich.
Und dann muss man gucken, ob man die noch flaschen kann.
Nicht mehr flashbar mit Tasmota.
Dann RIP.
Dann weiß ich gerade keine.
Dann kannst du bei Shelley mal gucken.
Die haben auf jeden Fall welche.
Aber die Shelley-Dinger sind halt teurer.
Die haben aber schon ohne zu flaschen.
Die kannst du flaschen, musst du aber nicht flaschen.
Die haben ohne flaschen schon eine...
... Firmware, die MQTT und HTTP API Unterstützung.
Tja, Leute, was meint ihr jetzt?
Wollen wir das anzeigen oder schließen?
Ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher dran.
Also, Products.
Zum Beispiel Shelley-Plug.
Nee, den meine ich nicht.
Ih, der sieht hässlich aus.
Plug S.
Ja, dieses Ding zum Beispiel.
Aber da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Da habe ich keinen von.
Ich habe bloß ein paar Tasmota-Gefleschte.
Ja, ich habe meine Heizung.
Habe ich drinnen.
Über V-Control D.
Und dann habe ich mir selbst dort nettenmäßig was gebaut.
Was über MQTT die Sachen announced und steuerbar macht.
Gibt es keine Alternative zu Tasmota?
Nee, ja, doch.
Es gibt ESP Home und solche Sachen.
Aber Tasmota ist für solche Geräte die beste Alternative, also die beste Firmware.
Problem ist, es liegt nicht an Tasmota, dass man die nicht mehr flaschen kann.
Es liegt an den Herstellern, die entweder kein ESP-866 mehr verbauen.
Was im Prinzip jegliche Firmware, die darauf basiert, nicht lauffähig macht.
Oder sie haben irgendeine so neue Version, dass man die nicht mehr flaschen kann.
Dass sie es eben absichtlich unterbinden zu flaschen.
Browser Addons.
Wirklich.
So, wir gucken jetzt aber erstmal, was in der Pipe unten ist.
Okay, es ist tatsächlich einfach.
Ein Rohr.
Wer hätte sich so denken können?
Sag mal Leute, ist das überhaupt noch das Rohr?
Das ist doch jetzt eigentlich Stein, oder?
Das ist nicht mehr das Rohr.
Ja, das ist Stein jetzt.
Da hat aber eine ordentlich gebohrt.
Geht das jetzt 8 Minuten so?
Oder kommt jetzt noch irgendein Jump Scare oder sowas?
Ich vermute, das geht einfach 8 Minuten so.
Ich spule mal kurz ein bisschen vor.
15 Millionen Views, Alter!
Da kommt gleich noch was, habe ich gerade gesehen.
Aha, da ist ein Loch.
Okay Leute, ernsthaft, das könnte In-Game-Grafik sein, oder?
Das könnte 1 zu 1 Horror-Game In-Game-Grafik sein.
Du erkennst nicht, ob es echt ist oder In-Game-Grafik.
Wo sind die denn da gelandet jetzt?
In der Höhle.
Okay, so.
Die Bahnhof-Demo habe ich gesehen, ja.
Okay, und du?
Und jetzt geht es wieder hoch.
Alter, das war ja das uselessste Video aller Zeiten.
Warum hat das 15 Millionen Views?
Ich meine, es ist immerhin kein Clickbait.
Es passiert genau das, was im Titel steht.
Sie lassen eine GoPro durch den Rohr runter und ziehen sie wieder raus.
Also Clickbait kann man da nicht vorwerfen.
Aber anscheinend, genau das, was sie machen, steht in der Beschreibung.
Warum das 15 Millionen Views hat, entzieht sich meinem Verständnis.
Aber okay.
Wenn sie meinen, ja.
Ach ja, Leute.
Ich hoffe, ihr seid wach.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen, ich habe Hunger.
PFSense oder Opensense?
Opensense.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen, Leute.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Vielleicht heute Abend, vielleicht noch erst nächste Woche.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Mal schauen.
Bis dann, macht's gut, CO.